programming throwdown episode 164 choosing a database for your project with chris zeip take it away jason hey everybody um. So Patrick and I have been doing a bunch of solo episodes or duo episodes, non-interview episodes. It's been really fun. But every now and then, an interview comes across a plate that is a really spectacular opportunity for us to dive into something that's really important, especially for folks that are just getting started. You might be in college and high school. You might not have a lot of years of experience under your belt. And one of the things that I didn't know until much, much later is the power and the usefulness of databases. I thought databases
were for financial folks or for people who are really professional, people who wore shirts with buttons. I thought databases were for them. And so as a high school student, college student, I was doing a lot with data structures that really should have been in databases. So we're going to talk about how to choose a database for your project and what different databases have to offer and how they can make things a lot easier. And with me, I have the SVP of engineering at HarperDB, Chris Zipe. So Chris, thank you so much for coming on the show. Thank you. I am delighted to be here.
Cool. So before we get into the topic, why don't you tell us a little bit about yourself? So how did you get into computing? Did you go to college for it? How did you kind of learn that trade? And how did you end up following the path to HarperDB? Sure. Well, it started when I was about 10. I grew up in a great family of school teachers, and they were alwayshertz, 20 megabyte drive and had Turbo Pascal. So I got started with Turbo Pascal when I was 10 and just dove into it and loved it, loved what I could do. I've always kind of been a do-it-yourselfer. So when I saw there was this new game called Tetris, I was like, I can do that write that play it myself so that's what i did i wrote tetris and turbo pascal was probably a terrible clone but whatever i had fun doing it's amazing did you share it with anybody or or was it a solo yeah this was before the open source world i think so um yeah and i wrote like a a check uh recording program for a chiropractor friend of mine when I was, I think, 13 or 14.
So that was great. I had a lot of experiences as a kid growing up programming. And so I even going into college, I knew I wanted to be involved in computers. So I did computer engineering at Oregon State and then computer science at University of Utah. And did interesting work on simulations with electromagnetics in the body at University of Utah. Oh, wow. So that, did you have a background in like magnetism and electromagnetism or was it more like you were the sort of engineer and you found yourself with these scientists?
So that was great. I had a lot of experiences as a kid growing up programming. And so even going into college, I knew I wanted to be involved in computers. So I did computer engineering at Oregon State and then computer science at University of Utah. And did interesting work on simulations with electromagnetics in the body at University of Utah. Oh, wow. So that, did you have a background in like magnetism and electromagnetism or was it more like you were the sort of engineer and you found yourself with these scientists?
It was more I was the engineer and I was, you know, handed a C framework for writing these simulations. And, you know, it was a great opportunity to learn more about physics and medicine and medical research. And so I really enjoyed getting to be a part of that. Wow, super cool wow super cool that is amazing one of the things i've come a very similar background to you and and um you know because we were kind of like pre-internet uh you know we didn't really have an opportunity to share a lot of projects and uh that is something that you folks today, you know, really take advantage of just the amazing community out there that, you know, is there's there's a whole community of folks that love to see what, you know, different different hobby projects and other things you're building. Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
So, yeah, that's amazing. Yeah. And then from there, I worked with a friend doing some consulting work with a company called Documentum that did database software. And then from there, that's when I actually really got involved in more in open source software. And I started working at a company called SitePen. They were kind of the main company behind the Dojo Toolkit, If you remember back in the days of the Dojo Toolkit. You know, I remember the name, but I forgot what it is. What is the Dojo Toolkit?
It was kind of like around the same time as jQuery. It actually came out a little bit before jQuery, but it was kind of in the similar vein of like, you know, a client side web toolkit that was filling in for all the crazy discrepancies between different browsers at the time and trying to provide a you know client-sided library um so i was a core contributor with with dojo for a while um and really kind of doubled down into open source got involved with like CommonJS committee, went to W3C and WTC39 meeting. I was the author of the JSON schema, the first draft of the JSON schema specification. Wow. Okay, wait, let's rewind a little bit, right? So we just talked about how it's kind of hard to get into, at least back in our day, it's
hard to get into communities. I definitely didn't have a Turbo Pascal community in my small town or anything like that. And so how did you break into that? Right. So, you know, W3C, you're writing the JSON schema. Like, how did you build up kind of that network over time? I mean, I was, you know, just working on open source software and like, you know, throwing projects open source software and like you know throwing projects out there and that was at the time when that was starting to really take off and in some ways it was actually i think easier at that time like now there's so much saturation of projects out there but back good point i mean that was around 2010 where like if you created a new like
you know you spent a couple days creating a new web framework or something like people actually paid attention, because like, there wasn't much else out there. So I think it was actually relatively easy to kind of like break in and start connecting with people and, you know, start emailing different people and talking about different ideas. And so, yeah, I was at a time where it was easy to get involved with what common js was doing and different groups were very cool standardization yeah yeah right and so and so while you're doing open source were you working at at companies that were very open source friendly like what's the sort of how's that symbiotic relationship work yeah well again, I was a company called SitePen. And we were really focused on Dojo at the time. So I was doing a lot of work for the Dojo framework, I did, did a lot to write their event handling, we had like a store interface for interacting with different data stores. So that was kind of like a little bit of bridging into database from the client side, and finding like, what are good common uniform interfaces for interacting with different data storage mediums. So I did a lot of work with that at the time. And but that also afforded just a lot
of opportunities to be involved in the broader JavaScript ecosystem at the time. Well, that makes sense. Very cool. And so what... Oh, go ahead. Yeah, sorry. Another thing I contributed to at the time was we also did... I wrote the original proposal for the Promises Ace specification. So that was kind of like
we had kind of put together some of the original ideas of what should promises look like in JavaScript. And the Promises A proposal is kind of actually what the original ideas of what should promises look like in JavaScript. And the promises a proposal is kind of actually what promises basically are these days, where when you call in a weight on a value, if it has a then method, that's kind of what defines it as a promise. And so I'm certainly not claiming to be like the originator of promises in JavaScript, but I had an opportunity to be involved in a lot of like the original
discussions about how that should work in JavaScript. That is really cool. I remember, and I don't know if promises weren't around or I just didn't know about them, but writing JavaScript without using the sort of async await is really painful. It's's like it's every function and then and then oh but any one of them could crash and if they do you have to roll back the parts that you did but that means you have to keep track of it everywhere it just like got
totally out of control um and yeah learning about that was a lifesaver yeah any and before promises it was like everything was just callbacks, right? Like, right. No JS applications. And it was just like, callback, callback, callback, callback. And every step had to have an air handler. And yeah, it was fun. Yeah, that was wild. So, so from CodePen, you at some point, you ended up at Harper. Why don't you talk about that? Were you there at the beginning? Or what's the Harper story like? Yeah, yeah.
So a little bit of a transition between then. So from SitePen, I went to a company called Dr. Evidence. Kind of an opportunity to go back into medical research a little bit with programming. And we were doing a lot of work with analyzing clinical studies. And these were like super, super complex data structures that were super nested. And we were doing a lot with, they were in like, you know, six normal form in a SQL database, you know, highly normalized, really well structured. But to load every study was like it took like several minutes to do the join that was required to pull a single study from this database and do
analysis on it and we you know we were trying to like create a user interface to do these these clinical analysis on on the fly in a few seconds and so that was kind of really where i got involved more at the lower level of like, we needed to build like caching. And so we were starting to use like, looking at key value stores, and we were using like level, level DB. And then I started becoming more interested in using LMDB, partly because it had multiprocess support, and it looked like it had very good performance characteristics. So that kind of started, I became, I kind of started using the existing LMDB JavaScript package. I kind of actually started taking over that package
and maintaining it and continuing to make advancements on it. And that was mainly to facilitate like this very, very like low latency interactions that we needed to do where we could like constantly be fetching different parts of these studies, facilitate like this very, very like low latency interactions that we needed to do where we could like constantly be fetching different parts of these studies, do analysis on it, fetch different parts, do natural language processing retrievals, pull all this data together. But it really needed to be like these database interactions needed to happen in microseconds. And so we needed like this low level capabilities to interact with this data.
And so I really got more and more invested in this low level and optimizing these low level interactions between JavaScript and LMDB. And it actually became reasonably popular, partly kind of transitively, Parcel and Gatsby, Kibana, which is used by Elasticsearch. They started using this package. And so it actually has like over half a million downloads on NPM, which isn't like wildly popular or anything, but it's enough. It's a really really cool popular package um and then i'd also develop some serialization deserialization libraries for message pack it's used with it as well which ultimately meant like we could get like microsecond level uh access to data from a data storage engine which was really cool how did you take it from like you, you said you were saying multiple seconds to, you know, let's say microseconds or even milliseconds.
You're talking about orders and orders of magnitude. Is it really just kind of changing technology? Was their code just broken? Or how did you get such dramatic speed up? Yeah, yeah. No, this is a fascinating part of it. You know, I mean, first of all, like going from, there's a lot of layers involved with just like the normal SQL query, right? Like you have parsing involved, you have network connection involved, you have serialization, deserialization involved.
There's a huge amount of complexity. If you are just like trying to retrieve a record by primary key, at the actual storage engine level, those things are insanely fast, like just doing a B tree retrieval is an extremely fast operation, and there's a huge amount of overhead. And so if you're just dealing with like, I need to fetch this data really quickly, I need to fetch that data really quickly first of all doing things in process with an embedded data storage engine is radically faster because you don't have any network overhead you don't have any sir you don't have as much serialization deserialization cost so that was kind of the first step but then as i was getting more into like optimizing uh this javascript like there's also like really fascinating
just weird things that you run into like the simple process of like having a memory pointer and then like being able to access that data with a memory with a you know like a c pointer that like is like the bread and butter of c programmingProgramming. Turning that over into JavaScript and getting a buffer that points to that same reference is like an insanely expensive operation. That allocation is actually really, really expensive in a JavaScript engine. And so there was a massive performance gain that could be had just by realizing
that if we just use the same allocated buffer over and over and copy data into it as the mechanism for that interface between the C-level and the JavaScript level, at least for small records, you get like a 10 times performance. You go from like, you know, 40 microseconds down to four microseconds or two microseconds. And so it was the combination of that and then employing like more sophisticated
deserialization techniques. It ends up that there's techniques you can use to do like message pack deserialization that are actually faster than JSON parse. So like we can do retrievals from the database, that single fetch can actually be performed from the database, retrieved from the database, deserialized in message pack faster than adjacent force can call with pre built with a pre built string. So it's kind of a big pile of different optimizations that came together to really achieve like, you know, this several microsecond level access to data. Yeah, that's amazing. Yeah, that's so satisfying with something like that. Because, you know this several microsecond level access to data yeah that's amazing yeah that's so satisfying with something like that because you know it's just it's just like a you
know you're marching towards something as you kind of hit that asymptote um yeah it's it's yeah i i love that that feeling where things get just super optimized over time yeah Yeah. Yeah. And so from there, I guess back to the journey, you know, I guess, like, to me, this was kind of like, maybe the the open source dream outcome is that like, make a kind of make an open source project, like it's fun to make an open source project. Cool to see some people use it. It's fun to see it kind of get moderately popular. And then I basically applied to HarperDB because they had been using LMDB.js. We actually call it lime juice so that we don't have to say six syllables, but they had been using LMDB.js. Yeah. And so like basically like make an open source project. And I got hired at a company to work on this open source project and build a database, build database software on top of it.
So that's kind of how I ended up at HarperDB was through this through this work on the data store level. Wow, that's amazing. So was it so you you kind of applied to HarperDB kind of as an individual. It wasn't part, you weren't part of a company acquisition or anything like that. No, no, nope. And yeah, I had had a number of interactions with like Kyle at HarperDB. And so we knew each other. I mean, we'd had, you know, a number of interactions on GitHub issues and, you know, I'd solved
some problems for them. And so when I applied, they were like, oh, it's Chris. That's awesome. Come join us. That is so cool. I'm hearing more and more of these of these stories, very similar to yours. And it's extremely inspiring. The one I saw, two of them I saw recently, one, and I'm'm not gonna butcher the person's name but the person who created fast api and sql model uh i'm gonna butcher it but it's it's uh last name is tangelo i think but he um he actually got into some kind of like incubator with sequoia Capital, which is a VC, a venture capitalist fund. And basically they just said, look, you have amazing open source projects.
We're just going to pay you to keep working on them. And it's an amazing relationship. And then the person who came up with llama.cpp, which is a way to run these, you know, ChatGPTlike open source, large language models, a way to run them really fast on the CPU. That person, same thing, they started a GitHub project
and started posting about it on Reddit. The GitHub project got really popular. They've just been spending just an insane amount of time on it. They've brought in Lama 2 and all these things that have just come out in the past couple of weeks this person's like totally on top of it and same kind of thing like a group of venture capital has got together and i think the person's in serbia so it's not even there's not really even like a personal connection but they just got together and and just funded this person like this is amazing and we want to be a part of it and so um um you know
and your story as well i think if you have that pension to create things um you know put it on github uh how do you actually you know to turn this into a question how do you build some word of mouth like you create um lime juice right and and so you you it. It's a GitHub project. You push the first version. It has zero stars, zero followers. What do you do next? How do you actually build it up? Yeah, I feel like you're asking the wrong person. I mean, I talked about it on Twitter some. And with the Lime Juice project, it was actually kind of a kind of a started as node LMDB. So there was already some existing users using that I kind of took over maintenance of it, and then basically kind of forked it with like some of the newer ideas that I wanted to implement to make things
faster. So there was kind of some natural, natural growth there. But yeah, I mean, I've, I've tried to talk about it on Twitter. And, you know, I think that then, from there, But yeah, I mean, I've, I've, I've tried to talk about it on Twitter and, you know, I think that then from there, you know, once you actually get a little bit of a foothold, like you see some other projects using something. And so I think it's kind of just organically grown from there, but I'm the last person in the world to talk about how to be effective in marketing open source projects. Well, I mean, it goes to show how good the, you know, how healthy the system is, right? That, you know, you can focus on making good content and, uh, and, and through, through the power of, of all of the, the internet, you know, the collective consciousness of
humanity here, we can all start to find those amazing projects. Yeah, for sure. I agree. Yeah. I think it's similar with eternal terminal. I had a buddy call me a few days ago saying, oh, he has some eternal terminal issue at work. And they were asking who can, who knows anything about this? And he said, oh, I know the guy who wrote that. And so he called me and was asking me some questions around. It was pretty esoteric, you know, SSH type stuff. But same kind of thing.
No real promotion or anything. And, you know, I've created hundreds of projects. And that's the only one that's really taken off to that degree. And it's just, you know, you can't at least I can't really predict it. But when you do find something that that sort of strikes that chord, it's just, you know, you can't, at least I can't really predict it. But when you do find something that sort of strikes that chord, it's really satisfying. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. Yeah.
And there's actually been projects I've had where it's been frustrating that they aren't seen by more people. And then I've had projects that it's like, please stop using this. It's too many people are using it. Yeah. like, please stop using this. It's too many people are using it. I had developed one of the early JSON schema implementations and didn't do a good job of maintaining it, but it has a ton of NPM downloads that, I mean, it'll continue to exist and I'll keep it out there, but it's not something I continue to work on.
So, yeah, that's really difficult because you only have so many hours in a day. But but it is it is hard to see the issues pile up. I actually last week I went through and addressed like so many issues in Eternal Terminal, but they're just piling up way higher than I can really address. Maybe one day, I know so many folks try to talk about we can build a marketplace economy on top of GitHub. So many
companies have tried this. It almost is starting to become a tar pit idea. Have you heard of this term? A tar pit idea is something that's so appealing. It feels like a warm bath, but you get in and you're stuck and your company dies. Yeah. So a personal CRM tarpid idea, like Facebook for X, Uber for X, these are all tarpid ideas.
And I feel like monetizing GitHub is starting to become a tarpid ideas and i feel like you know yeah like monetizing github is starting to become a tarpid idea um but but i i do think that you know like eternal term is a great example i mean there's so many people using it that and your json schema is another even better example you know somebody should be able to make a modest living making that library better um and we really just don't have the marketplace for it but i think there's there's just there's just so many moving parts it's hard to really get that right yep you're absolutely right yeah and i agree it's this one of those things where i would love it if that could be reality i don't know how to make it reality yeah so many smart people have tried i'm a little afraid to to make it reality. Yeah. Yeah. So many smart people have tried.
I'm a little afraid to, to, uh, it's like saying Voldemort or something, right? Yeah. Um, well,
that's amazing. So, so you've been, how long have you been at Harper? Um, I've actually been there for just a little over a year, about a year and a half now. So.
Cool. Great. And is it, uh, we'll get more into the company, you know, after we talk about the main topic, but I'm just curious, is it a remote thing where are you all together or is it distributed? Yes, it is. I mean, there's a number of people, our headquarters are in Denver and there's a number of people that are out there.
I live in Salt Lake City. And so most of the engineers are working remotely um it's nice to actually be in the same same time zone i worked for many years i've actually this is i think 15th year that i've been working remotely so the previous companies were in oh wow yeah but so this has been just kind of a normal transition for me covid didn't affect work at all for me. Yeah, that's right. I just needed to work remotely. Yeah, very cool. Great. We'll definitely put a bookmark in that. I definitely want to talk more about Harper and that database. But we'll kind of step out here and talk about just choosing the right database.
And maybe before we even do that, we should talk a little bit about what is a database, you know, kind of in practical terms, like why would someone use a database versus using a B-tree library or some, you know, some JavaScript library for storing data? You know, when should people make that decision? Yeah, that's a good question. I mean, there actually are probably times people can use a B-tree library directly, but there certainly is a tremendous amount of functionality that is built on top of the host B-tree libraries that you typically use in a day to day work with databases. You know, databases handle the work of maintaining data in a structured format so that you actually instead of just having raw binary data, it's in the form of actual fields or properties or columns. search for records by different values and perform that efficiently, handles things like transactions,
ensuring that multiple things can be handled atomically with isolation, consistency, ensuring that it's stored on the disk drives in a durable, reliable way. Databases can get into the issues of management, observability, and then being able to provide higher level queries. You know, obviously, many of us use databases through SQL queries, which gives us a much easier way of thinking about querying data than having to think about interacting with individual indices and B-trees and how those are connected and related. So that's kind of broadly why we use databases is it gives us the ability to interact with
complex data using relatively simple mechanisms for querying and updating that data. I think it's interesting, too, like you mentioned, Chris, I I think maybe in some cases you don't need a database. I think we were having this a little bit debate maybe in the pre-show of what makes a database a database. I feel like it's expanded a lot. So, you know, something from like a key value store, you know, can still be a database. And then you were mentioning a lot of things, which I think hits upon things that folks miss, which is how many users are you talking about? Is there contention for data or not contention? So in other words, does your application running in multiple places need to make updates to the same data or not is a big one. And then for internal tooling,
it may be that each person is kind of by construction doing something slightly different. And so really, it's more of a caching transmission mechanism thing, in which case it's different. But then you mentioned schemas as well. I think that's one that we were referencing JSON earlier. But people maybe not with JSON schema, but with just JSON plain, we'll just insert a new field, right? And then stuff will break there's no like planned way of dealing with it and everyone says well you don't need that stuff i'll just figure it out and it's like well yeah you're right that is true but at what cost and indexes is another big one you mentioned that's fallen to the same bucket if you just put opaque binary data you know in blob somewhere somehow stored could you write something to like extract
and index the fields you want to dub that? Yes. And are you going to write a bunch of code that already is battle tested, robust and going to do a better job than you? Hey, I just going to reinvent a crappier version of like existing indexers. So there's not this like hard line, but I think early on, sitting down and really thinking about what you're optimizing for and targeting makes a big difference in in what you select and then also like you mentioned is it going to be sql interface or not and what is the implications of saying hey i'm just going to shove random json objects i'll keep beating on j i should do something else random you know jpeg pictures in these columns right like well wait a minute hang hang on. Like SQL is not going to buy you much
if all your data columns are JPEGs. I'm not, I mean, maybe it does. Maybe I'm not an expert there. It feels like it probably doesn't buy you as much, right? Could you do it? Sure, but it's not like a good choice. And so I think you end up with classically extremists on both ends, you know, no database
or everything in the database. And in reality, it's probably a little bit more fluid. Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. Yeah, you're right. Those are some great examples of where, you know, this is the reason why like Redis and Memcached and different things like that have really grown in popularity is because they are fulfilling a role of this, you know, high speed access to data that doesn't need the extra overhead of a full SQL engine. So that does illustrate some of the different needs of databases.
And one of the challenges is, I think maybe one of the primary drivers for what database you're going to use is, what is the hardest thing the database is going to do in terms of querying? And it's hard to figure that out ahead of time, right? Like, what is the most difficult query going to be? Is it just going to be these like, by key lookups?
Or is it going to be, you know, a three level join or something like that? So yeah, kind of thinking ahead about that. And then the other aspect is like, what are the data structures look like? Like, you know, traditional databases have had, you know, tables with a relatively flat structure of columns that each can have a field in it. And part of the driver for like NoSQL databases, document driven databases is the idea that, you know, when we are working with data in typical programming languages, like it can be very
或者你知道，它会是一个三层连接（join）之类的东西？所以，是的，要提前考虑这一点。另一个方面是，数据结构看起来是什么样的？你知道，传统数据库的表格结构相对扁平，每列都可以有一个字段。而无SQL（NoSQL）数据库、文档驱动数据库的部分驱动力在于，当我们使用典型的编程语言处理数据时，可以非常
convenient to think about data as nested structures right like i have an object and inside that object is an array and inside of that array is a set of objects and that's really convenient when i'm working in a programming language when i translate that to a relational model now i'm starting to get into junction tables and joins and things like that, that like, hey, I thought this was supposed to be pretty easy, or it felt really easy in my programming language. And now it's getting more complicated. So certainly data structures influence that as well as just how am I going to be accessing that data? Oh, that's interesting. I hadn't thought about this actually.
把数据想象成嵌套结构会非常方便，对吧？比如我有一个对象，对象里面有一个数组，数组里面又有一组对象。当我在编程语言中工作时，这非常方便。但当我把它转换成关系模型时，现在我开始接触到连接表（junction tables）、连接（joins）以及类似的东西，我会想：“等等，这应该挺简单才对，或者在我的编程语言里感觉挺简单的，现在怎么变得更复杂了？”因此，数据结构肯定会影响这一点，以及我将如何访问这些数据？哦，这很有意思。我之前其实没想过这一点。
That explains the rise of the ORM as well, right? So the object relational model. The sort of middleware. So if you talk about like a Ruby on Rails person would just go, no, this is no problem. I got you. And they would sort of just attack it, right? By saying, hey, I'm just going to basically,
这也解释了ORM的兴起，对吧？也就是对象关系模型。也就是那种中间件。所以如果你谈论一个Ruby on Rails开发者，他会直接说：“没问题，这交给我。”然后他们就会着手解决，对吧？通过说：“嘿，我基本上要……”
I don't call it what you want, middleware, ORM. I don't even know all the terms. But basically, how do I take a structured in-memory view and then sort of push it into the correct representation in a database and have that be, I'll call it a translator, back and forth between the two sides of the system, or even do joins or queries on the back end appropriately so that you're trying to get the best of both worlds by having a description in the middle. Right, right, right, so that you trying to get the best of both worlds by by having a description in the middle. Right, right, right, for sure. Yeah. Yeah. And one of the realizations people have is like, okay, if, if I have like an array of objects, again, inside of my object, and it only belongs inside of that object, the relational, the traditional relational model for that where you have the object and then maybe
我不叫它你想要的中间件或ORM，我甚至连所有的术语都不知道。但基本上，我该如何获取一个结构化的内存视图，然后将其推送到数据库中的正确表示形式，并让它——我称之为翻译器——在系统的两侧之间来回转换，甚至在后端适当地执行连接或查询，这样你就可以通过在中间加一个描述，来试图获得两全其美的效果？对，对，对，所以你通过在中间加一个描述，来试图获得两全其美的效果。对，对，对，确实如此。是的。是的。人们意识到的一点是，好吧，如果，如果我的对象里面，再次包含一个对象数组，而且它只属于该对象内部，那么针对这种情况的传统关系模型——即你有一个对象，然后可能是
the other table and it's joined and you may even have junction tables in between that's actually pretty complicated if all i want is this single you know thing this single document right um which could very well just be a single lookup in a B-tree. And so part of this is, how is that data structured in terms of ownership? Is this hierarchy completely contained within objects themselves? Or are these arrays like references to other objects that are then shared? And in that sense, then the relational model starts making more sense. You have these relationships between these objects and these other objects that are then shared. And that in that sense, then the relational model starts making more sense, you know, you have these relationships between these objects,
另一个表，并且进行了连接，你甚至可能在中间有连接表——如果我想要的只是这个单一的，你知道的东西，这个单一的文档，其实相当复杂。嗯，这很可能只是B树中的一次单次查找。所以其中一部分是，就所有权而言，这些数据是如何组织的？这种层级结构是完全包含在对象本身之中的吗？还是说这些数组是指向其他对象的引用，然后这些对象被共享了？从这个意义上说，关系模型就开始变得更有意义了。这些对象与这些随后被共享的其他对象之间存在着这些关系。从这个意义上说，关系模型就开始变得更有意义了，你知道的，这些对象之间存在着这些关系，
these other objects, if I can denormalize, if I can normalize them, sorry, if I can normalize them, you know, there's certainly benefits to normalization in terms of like one, you know, one, one source of truth as far as where a record goes, and then the joins start making more sense. But so there's a lot of questions just in terms of what do those data structures look like and how do those map to a database appropriately? Yeah, that makes sense. I think that you touched on something really important
这些其他对象，如果我能进行反规范化，如果我能对它们进行规范化——抱歉，如果我能对它们进行规范化——你知道，规范化肯定有其好处，比如关于记录归宿的单一真实数据源（one source of truth），然后连接（joins）开始变得更有意义。因此，仅仅是这些数据结构是什么样的，以及如何将它们正确映射到数据库中，就有很多问题需要考虑。是的，这说得通。我觉得你触及了一个非常重要的点：
where even without a database, you know, like, kind of circular dependencies and circular references become really difficult to manage. Like, you know, even imagine like an email app. So you have email folders. Imagine you're trying to write this without a database, you know, and then you have a bunch of email objects. And so the folder has a list of objects. Each of the objects needs to know what folder it's in. And so if you don't do this right, you end up with this kind of pointer nightmare where if you want to move an email
即甚至在没有数据库的情况下，你知道，循环依赖和循环引用也会变得非常难以管理。比如，你知道，甚至想象一下电子邮件应用。所以你有邮件文件夹。想象一下你试图在没有数据库的情况下编写这个程序，然后你有一堆邮件对象。所以文件夹有一个对象列表。每个对象都需要知道自己属于哪个文件夹。如果你没有正确处理这一点，你最终会陷入一种指针噩梦：如果你想把一封邮件
from one folder to the other, first you have to delete it from the folder list. Then you have to also tell it that it's now part of another folder. So you end up having to change like three places. And if your app crashes or if something happens, I have to roll that back and it just becomes really difficult and um you know i remember sql normalization was really popular
从一个文件夹移动到另一个文件夹，首先你必须把它从文件夹列表中删除。然后你还必须告诉它现在属于另一个文件夹。所以你最终不得不修改三个地方。如果你的应用崩溃了或者发生了什么状况，我必须回滚这些操作，这就会变得非常困难，而且……嗯，我记得SQL规范化非常流行，
in the late 90s early 2000s where people said oh you just have to follow these rules and if you follow these rules then you will always have kind of a perfectly normalized world. And so we did follow these rules. And as you said, we ended up with so many different joins. It's like, oh, a person could have at most two phone numbers. But instead of having a phone number one and a phone number two column, which would be super easy, instead, now we're going to join to this table. As you said, junction table joins to another table of like you know user id phone numbers and so then you end up having to write this really complicated query to pull an entire entire object and so there is sort of a lot of like
在90年代末和2000年代初，当时人们说：“哦，你只需要遵循这些规则，如果你遵循了这些规则，那么你将永远拥有一个完美的规范化世界。”所以我们确实遵循了这些规则。正如你所说，我们最终得到了太多的连接（joins）。就像是：“哦，一个人最多可以有两个电话号码。”但我们没有采用“电话号码1”和“电话号码2”这两列（这会超级简单），而是现在我们要连接到这个表。正如你所说，连接表（junction table）连接到另一个表，比如用户ID和电话号码，于是你最终不得不编写一个非常复杂的查询来拉取一整块对象。所以这里面有相当多……
deceivingly complicated uh design decisions you have to make there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you're absolutely right. You know, we, we kind of grew up with normalization and cod we trust. And when he taught his first normalization goes, but, you know, the last decade or two, really has been characterized more by like, trying to figure out where is the appropriate place to denormalize that data. And that doesn't necessarily is not necessarily mutually exclusive with normalization. You know, there's a lot of systems out there that do have like a source of truth normalization, but caching layers that do some of this denormalization where, you know, you have a derived version of that record where the phone numbers are in line, and you can very, very quickly and easily access
看似简单但实则复杂的架构决策，你必须在那里做出选择。是的，是的，是的。你说得完全对。你知道，我们可以说是伴随着规范化和科德（Codd）的信任长大的。当他教授他的第一条规范化规则时，但是，过去的一二十年，其特征实际上更倾向于试图弄清楚在哪里对数据进行反规范化才是合适的地方。这并不一定与规范化相互排斥。你知道，有很多系统确实拥有作为真实数据源的规范化（source of truth normalization），但也拥有做这种反规范化处理的缓存层，在这里，你知道，你拥有该记录的一个派生版本，其中的电话号码是内联的，你可以非常非常快速且轻松地访问
that. And so I think that a lot of the evolution of database has been learning to what are the appropriate ways to do this denormalization. It can go too far the other way too, right? Where you can have so much data that denormalized that it becomes inefficient to store this. And so you start looking at ways where maybe a simple key value store that just is doing this massive denormalization is a little too simplified. You want to do some denormalization. You want to have some relationships in that
它。所以我觉得数据库的大部分演变过程，一直在学习如何以合适的方式来进行这种反规范化。当然，它也可能走向另一个极端，对吧？就是你可能会把太多数据进行反规范化，以至于存储这些数据变得效率低下。因此，你开始寻找这样一种方法：也许一个简单的键值存储（key-value store）——它只是在做这种大规模的反规范化——有点过于简化了。你希望做一些反规范化。你希望其中有一些关系
that are kind of normalized to other parts. And so I think that that hybrid is really maybe the direction that we're starting to learn in terms of getting in between the two pendulum swings and having efficient data storage. Yeah, totally. you serialize in C++ or something, you want to change as your product changes. And change becomes really, really, really difficult. Changing, but keeping backwards compatibility, handling migrations. If you saved your data a year ago and you find oh i need some of those records i need to to retrieve something and so now i need to to uh you know mutate all of this year-old data
与其他部分进行某种程度的规范化。所以我想这种混合模式（hybrid）确实可能是我们开始学习的方向，即在两个摆动之间找到平衡，实现高效的数据存储。是的，完全同意。你在C++或其他语言中进行序列化时，随着产品的改变，你会希望做出改变。而改变会变得非常、非常、非常困难。改变的同时还要保持向后兼容性，处理数据迁移（migrations）。如果你一年前保存了数据，然后发现“哦，我需要其中一些记录，我需要检索某些东西”，所以现在我需要……嗯，对所有这些一年的老旧数据进行突变（mutate），
so that it can work with my modern software um these things are incredibly incredibly difficult to do yourself and so um the database that i'm most familiar with being a python guy is is um is a sql alchemy with alembic um and so what what that does is alembic is this tool where you you try your best not to change the database in the database um You try to use Alembic to say, create a row, create a column, or change this type to an int, or create a new table, create a junction table. And as long as you do everything in Alembic,
以便它能与我现代的软件协同工作——这些事情如果你自己做的话，真的是难上加难。所以……嗯，作为一个Python开发者，我最熟悉的数据库是带有Alembic的SQLAlchemy。所以，Alembic的作用是，它是一个让你尽量不在数据库本身中直接修改数据库的工具。
it's keeping track of all these changes. And then you now have this ledger. So if I have year-old data i know exactly what my database schema was like a year ago and i can tell alembic you know take this database and bring it up to modern standards and it will execute all of these steps and and and so under the hood is a is a ton of complexity there um i would say maybe just to tie it off like uh you know i think that databases will force you to be more disciplined um that that they'll they'll force you to do things that you can't if you're doing all sorts of pointer tricks and things like that um but from
你尝试使用Alembic来创建行、创建列，或者将这种类型更改为整数（int），或者创建新表、创建连接表。只要你在Alembic中完成所有这些操作，它就会跟踪所有这些更改。然后你现在就有了这个分类账（ledger）。所以如果我有一年前的数据，我就能准确知道一年前我的数据库模式（schema）是什么样的，我可以告诉Alembic（你知道，把这个数据库提升到现代标准），它就会执行所有这些步骤。因此，在底层，那里存在着海量的复杂性。我想说的是，也许做个总结：数据库会迫使你更有纪律性，它们会强迫你去做一些如果你在使用各种指针技巧时无法做到的事情；但从
that from that discipline you'll end up with a better product that you can rely on. Yeah, yeah. And I think where that maybe is most, or at least a good example of it is when you're dealing with transactions. Transactions are one of those things where you never feel like you need it right from the get go, right? Like, you're like, oh, I want to update this. And then I want to update that, right? Like, why should I have to think about transactions, but it's part of the reason we do that is because like, once you realize, well, what do we have to do if one of these is, is updated, and this other thing isn't updated. And you start dealing with tons of edge cases that are just incredibly difficult to like think through like these types
这种纪律性中，你最终会得到一个你可以依赖的更好产品。是的，是的。我想这方面最典型（或者至少是一个好例子）的场景，就是当你处理事务（transactions）的时候。事务就是那种你从一开始就永远不会觉得自己需要它的东西，对吧？就像你会觉得：“哦，我想更新这个。然后我想更新那个，对吧？为什么我非得去考虑事务呢？”但我们之所以这么做，部分原因在于：一旦你意识到，如果其中一个更新了，而另一个没有更新，我们该怎么办？你就会开始处理无数的边缘情况（edge cases），这些边缘情况要在脑海中推演——比如这些中间状态以及其中涉及的竞态条件（race conditions）——简直难得令人发指。
of in-between states and the race conditions that are involved um and so i think you're absolutely right when we are forced to deal with data through transactions even though like sometimes that's a little bit annoying uh to start with uh you start it's it deals with this whole class of just really really painful problems and makes them a lot more tackleable yeah totally um cool so so let's see you know people are super excited now they want to you know you make their their new game engine use a database, how should they go about picking a good database? I have a list of topics here, and we'll kind of walk through them. The first one I have on my list is speed and latency. So different databases kind of make different trade-offs there.
所以我想你绝对没说错，当我们被迫通过事务来处理数据时，尽管有时一开始会觉得有点烦人，但它确实能够解决一整类非常、非常棘手的问题，并使它们变得容易应对得多。是的，完全同意。太酷了。那么，让我们看看，你知道，人们现在超级兴奋，他们想要让他们的全新游戏引擎使用数据库，他们应该如何着手挑选一个好的数据库呢？我这里有一个主题列表，我们可以顺着过一遍。我列表上的第一个是速度和延迟。不同的数据库在这方面会做出不同的权衡。
Why would everyone want a slower database? What are the things that those databases are doing with that time? And what's the reasons for that? Yeah, I don't think any of your listeners are out here looking for, what is the slowest database I can find? Maybe I can get advice on how to find that. So obviously that is a trade-off. There are reasons why people have ended up with slower databases.
为什么每个人都会想要一个较慢的数据库？那些数据库在这段时间里都在做些什么？原因是什么？是的，我觉得你们的听众里应该没有人会去寻找：“我能找到的最慢的数据库是什么？也许有人能给我一些建议，告诉我怎么找到它。”所以，这显然是一种权衡。人们最终使用较慢的数据库是有原因的。
And there's a lot of applications that simply cannot sacrifice when it comes to speed. You know, oftentimes when you're dealing with things that are directly driving user interfaces or even more so maybe part of gaming, like, you know, speed is like, you can't sacrifice. Whereas oftentimes, the things that will drive slower speeds is when you are dealing with something where there's higher levels of data consistency requirements. When you get into financial applications, like, there's pretty, pretty strict requirements about like, things not only being transactional, but like making sure that you are like fully coordinating any systems involved, that you have all the correct checks in place that you have the correct ability to roll back if anything doesn't look correctly. And that is a very different scenario
而且有许多应用程序在速度方面是绝对不能妥协的。你知道，通常当你处理直接驱动用户界面的事情，或者更多时候可能是游戏的一部分时，速度是无法妥协的。然而，往往导致速度变慢的情况是，当你处理对数据一致性要求更高的场景时。当你进入金融应用领域时，有着相当严格的要求：不仅要具备事务性，还要确保你完全协调了涉及的所有系统，确保你拥有所有正确的检查机制，确保如果任何地方看起来不对劲时，你都有正确的回滚能力。这是一个非常不同的场景，
than, say, a database that's maintaining the positions of the players in a game, for example, or something like that, where the speed requires very, very low latency. Certainly, there are situations where things are slow just because it does involve complex queries. And oftentimes, that's well-rec well recognized by the people that are making the query is like hey I'm doing this thing that is doing searching for a
比方说，一个维护游戏中玩家位置的数据库，或者类似的事情，那里的速度需要极低的延迟。当然，有些情况下速度慢只是因为它涉及复杂的查询。而且通常，进行查询的人非常清楚这一点，他们会觉得：“嘿，我在做这件事，它正在一个庞大的数据库中搜索一套非常、非常复杂的不同条件。”很多时候，双方都意识到这将是一件困难的事。这需要花一些时间。所以，我认为这其中肯定有这些不同的方面。是的，这说得通。完全说得通。是的，我的意思是，有一种关于“过早优化是万恶之源”的说法。我想是唐纳德·克努特（Donald Knuth）说的，但……但我觉得再次强调，
through a huge database for a very very complex set of different conditions and the obvious a lot of times there's a recognition on both sides that this is going to be difficult. It's going to take a while. So there's certainly those different aspects of it, I think. Yeah, that makes sense. Totally makes sense. Yeah, I mean, there's a saying kind of premature optimizations, root of evil kind of saying. I think it's Donald newt who said that but um but i think again if
如果你正在使用一个数据库……你知道，不是某种自制的东西，而是你在使用一个常见的数据库，那么从一个数据库迁移到另一个数据库将会相对容易，所以你总是可以从任何最方便的东西开始。如果你突然发现某个政府机构想要使用我的产品，并且他们要求数据必须是一致的，那么你可以切换到另一个数据库。或者，如果延迟是个真正的问题，并且你愿意接受最终一致性（eventually consistent），那么你也可以选择另一种方式。对，是的，这绝对有相应的机会。而且就像编程中的任何事情一样，你希望第一次就把它做好，因为切换是需要付出工作的，但我们一直在这么做。没错，没错。是的，完全同意。好的，我列的下一个是可扩展性（scalability）。
you're if you're using a database um um you know not not some kind of homebrew thing but you're using a common database it will be relatively easy to migrate from one database to another and so you can always start with you know whatever is the most convenient. And if you find that all of a sudden some government agency wants to use my product and they are demanding that it's consistent, then you can switch to another database. Or if the latency is a real problem and you're willing to be eventually consistent, then you can go the other way as well. right yeah there definitely are opportunities for that and you know like anything in programming like you want to get it right the first time because there is work involved in switching but we do it all the time yep yep yeah totally okay, the next one I have is scalability.
这里浮现出的一个例子是SQLite。我几乎总是在每个项目开始时都使用SQLite。也许这同样是因为我是一个Python开发者，并且在使用SQLAlchemy，从SQLite切换到其他东西非常简单。所以我总是会在SQLite中开始项目，测试项目，测试想法。对于那些不知道的人来说，SQLite是一个完整的SQL数据库。你可以针对它编写查询。你可以使用select语句、update。
One thing that comes to mind here is SQLite. I almost always start every project with SQLite. And maybe this is, again, because I'm a Python guy and I'm using SQL Alchemy, it's very simple to switch from SQLite to something else. And so I'll always start projects in SQLite, test out the project, test out the idea. Just for people who don't know, SQLite is a fully SQL database. You can write queries against it. You can just select statements, updates.
你可以创建表。你可以完成所有这些操作。但数据库实际上只是你电脑上的一个文件，或者可能是一个装满文件的文件夹，我记不清了……哦，不对，它实际上就是一个文件，是一个.sqlite文件。所以……现在那个文件可能会非常巨大，如果你在里面放了大量数据的话，但它确实非常优雅，因为你不需要担心网络或任何此类事情。
You can create tables. You can do all of that. But the database is literally just a file on your computer or maybe a folder full of files i don't remember but uh oh no it's literally just one file it's a dot sqlite file and so um now that file could be enormous right if you're putting a lot of data in it but but that it's it's really elegant in the sense that you don't have to worry about networking or any of that um the downside is only one process can write to the file at a time ever so so you're not going to build facebook on sqlite it's just not going to happen um and uh and so invariably you have to move to something
它的缺点是：一次只能有一个进程写入文件，永远如此。所以你不会在SQLite上构建Facebook，这是根本不可能发生的。因此，你总是不可避免地要迁移到其他东西上去。但是……拥有可扩展性，你知道，之所以在那个光谱上有那么多不同的数据库，是因为如果你愿意接受那些高度受限的环境——比如把所有东西都在一个文件上运行——你确实可以获得速度和延迟，还能获得非常流畅的开发者体验。所以，SQLite实际上非常强大，即使它的可扩展性不是很好。是的，这其实是一个嵌入式数据库的绝佳例子。就像你说的，是的，能够直接在进程中访问该数据库，有着巨大的性能优势，你消除了很多额外的跳转。但总的来说，随着你的扩展，
else but um um but having the the scalability you know the different the reason why there's so many different databases on that spectrum is because you do get um you know speed and latency and you get a really smooth developer experience um if you're willing to have those really constrained environments like running everything off of a file. And so, so SQLite is actually extraordinarily powerful, even if it's not very scalable. Yeah. And that actually is a great example of an embedded database. And like you're saying, yeah, there's huge, there's actually big performance benefits of being able to directly access that data in process, you eliminate a lot of extra hops. But yeah, generally as you're scaling,
你会希望达到这样一种状态：你可以运行在多进程、多线程甚至多服务器上。这是可扩展性的很大一部分，即：我们有哪些方法可以进行垂直扩展（vertically scale），以确保我们充分利用了现代服务器的高多核机器？我们能否扩展到越来越大的存储空间？这一直是数据库的一个经典问题：
you are wanting to achieve a state where, you can be running on multiple processes, multi threads, even multiple servers. And that's a big part of scalability is, what are the ways that we can vertically scale to make sure that we're leveraging, you know, highly multi-core machine of modern, modern servers? Are we going to be able to scale to larger and larger storage? And this is always kind of a classic issue with
如果你在对数据进行索引（indexing），并且你只是在做全表扫描（full table scans），那么它在小表上其实总是非常、非常快的。任何数据库工作的真正挑战不在于我如何查询数据，而在于我如何以一种能够确保随着数据变大而保持快速的方式来查询数据？我想，这无论如何一直是最大的挑战，也就是确保我能够做到这一点。而且当你开始构建应用程序时，这往往具有某种欺骗性，因为再次强调，一切刚开始时都很快。但是……你总是必须考虑：一旦数据库达到几吉字节（gigabytes）或几太字节（terabytes）时，这个查询还会快吗？并且它能维持那种
databases is that if you are indexing data and you're just doing full table scans, it's always actually really, really fast. All queries are really, really fast on small tables. The real challenge with any database work is not how do I query the data, but how do I query the data in a way that's guaranteed to stay fast as the data gets bigger? That's always the challenge, I think, anyway, is, is making sure that I can do that. And it's that's can always be kind of deceptive, when you start building an application, because again, like everything is fast when you get going. But like, you're always, you always have to be thinking about, well, is this query going to be fast once the database is several gigabytes or several terabytes and is going to maintain that
速度吗？所以有这方面的问题。是的，正如你所说……其他可扩展性是水平扩展（horizontal scaling），我们甚至有可能跨多台机器运行这个数据库吗？如果我们对一台机器来说变得太大了怎么办？然后你就会开始遇到以下问题：数据库之间是如何进行集群（cluster）、复制（replication）或分片（sharding）的。所以这些绝对涉及扩展数据库更复杂的方面。但这些都是与之相关的各种考量。是的，这说得通。我一直对这一点感到很好奇，也许你能帮我阐明一下。我的意思是，有一些单节点数据库，
speed so there's that aspect of it and yeah like you were saying um other scalability is horizontal scaling can we run this database even potentially across multiple machines what if we get too big for for one machine and then you start getting into issues of how do the databases cluster, replicate, or shard with each other. And so those definitely get into more complicated aspects of scaling a database. But those are all kinds of the different concerns related to it. Yeah, that makes sense. I was always kind of curious about this, and maybe you can help elucidate it for me. I mean, there's sort of single node databases
比如SQLite，伯克利DB（Berkeley DB）是另一个例子。然后还有多节点数据库，从Postgres和MySQL到HBase、Dynamo以及所有其他这些数据库。然后似乎人们会说这样的话：“MySQL的可扩展性没那么好。”
like SQLite, for example, Berkeley DB is another example. And then there's, you know, multi-node, which would be everything from like Postgres and MySQL to HBase to Dynamo to all of these other ones. And then it seemed like people were saying things like, MySQL doesn't scale as well.
我记得当NoSQL大火的时候，他们主推的一点是它具有更好的可扩展性，你可以将Cassandra、HBase或其中之一扩展到Postgres无法企及的极端程度。但我从来没有真正理解为什么会这样，或者这究竟是真的还是只是营销手段。所以一旦你转向多节点，那里存在一个连续统（spectrum），还是说它们基本上都差不多？
I remember when NoSQL became a big thing, the thing that they were pushing was that it was just way more scalable, that you could scale something like Cassandra or HBase or one of these ones to an extraordinary degree that you couldn't scale Postgres to. But I never really understood why or if that was true or just marketing. So once you go multi-node, is there a spectrum there or are they all pretty much the same?
是的，我的意思是，我认为那里绝对存在一个连续统。我想你切中的要点是：你在关系型数据库中通常能获得的许多保证，在分布式网络中实际上很难维持。比如，仅仅拥有表的一部分子集并在其上做正确的二级索引（secondary indexing）。为了获得一致的二级索引，整个表必须都在那里。当你开始处理诸如外键约束（foreign key constraints）和级联删除（cascading deletes）之类的事情时，要在整个分布式网络中一致地维护这些东西，实际上真的、真的非常困难。所以，当你只是把传统数据库现有的的一致性保证，试图扩展到一个分布式网络时，情况就相当复杂了。因此，你最终会陷入这样一种境地：你试图决定，“好吧，我们真正需要的保证到底是什么？”NoSQL数据库在分布式方面的一个优势，就是省去了这些约束，可以说是从一张白纸开始，
Yeah, I mean, I think there's definitely a spectrum there. And I think what you're hitting on is that a lot of the guarantees that you would typically get in a relational database are actually quite difficult to maintain in a distributed network. like just have a partial set of a table and do correct secondary indexing on it. Like the whole table has to be there to get a coherent secondary index. When you start dealing with things like foreign key constraints and cascading deletes, those are actually really, really difficult to maintain consistently across a distributed network. And so when you just take like the existing consistency guarantees of a traditional database, and then just try to scale that to a distributed network, it's fairly complicated. So you eventually end up with situations where you are trying to decide, OK, what are the guarantees that we really need. And one of the advantages that NoSQL databases had in terms of distribution was kind of starting without those constraints, kind of starting with this blank slate of like,
“好吧，我们要思考，假设我们身处分布式网络中，我们能够提供的保证级别是多少，并且不提供任何我们无法支持的保证。”所以它是采用了这种不同的方法。当然，MySQL和许多这类数据库肯定也做了大量值得称赞的工作，试图更好地完成扩展。有时，这可能涉及一些更复杂的事情，比如分片（sharding），这需要相当程度的投入来
okay, we are going to think about what is the level of guarantees that we can provide, assuming that we are going to be in a distributed network and not providing any guarantees that we can't back up. And so it was kind of taking that different approach. And there's certainly ways that, you know, I mean, MySQL and a lot of these databases certainly have done a valiant job of trying to, you know, do better jobs of scaling. And sometimes, like, that can involve, like, things that are a little bit more complex, like sharding, like that involves a fair degree of like involvement in trying to
理解：这些数据究竟该如何分布？所以，这绝对有相应的应对方法，但是把单节点的ACID期望的那种保证，带入并试图在整个分布式网络中保证同样的事情，
understand, well, how can this data be distributed? So there's, there's certainly approaches, but like carrying those, those guarantees of how acid expectations worked with a single node, and then trying to guarantee those same things
这是一个非常难以跨越的跨度。明白了，是的，这说得通。是的，我想是Planet Base（或者Neon？我记得是Planet Base）实际上禁用了外键。所以你必须自己处理级联删除和所有这些事情。但他们从中获得的好处可能是好得多的可扩展性。是的，我记得我听过你关于这个的播客。我想当他这么说的时候，我的反应是：“没错，这正是你绝对不想尝试在分布式网络中去做的事情。”是的，为听众稍微深入探讨一下。
across the distributed network is a difficult difficult leap to make got it yeah that makes sense um yeah i think it's planet base i want to say one of them might be neon it's i think planet base plant base actually bans foreign keys. And so you have to do the cascading deletes and all of that yourself. But what they get from that is probably much better scalability. Yeah, I think I remember listening to your podcast on this. And I think when he said that, I was like, yes, that is the thing that you do not want to attempt to do across the distributed network. Yeah, just to dive in a little bit on that for the audience.
所以假设你有一个用户账户，用户有电话号码、信用卡、交易记录，然后他们说：“我希望你删除我的账户，而且我是指真正的删除，不像谷歌或Facebook那样只是永远保留你的数据，而是真正的删除。”
So imagine you have a user account, the user has phone numbers, they have credit cards, they have transactions, and then they say, I want you to delete my account, and I want it actually deleted, not like Google or Facebook deleted where they just keep your data forever, but actually deleted.
所以你必须执行（你知道，你删除了那个账户），然后你还必须删除所有从该账户派生出来的其他东西。这就是“级联”这个比喻的由来，因为它会级联到信用卡表、电话号码表以及所有这些表中。所以然后，你知道，为了快速做到这一点，你需要以某种方式保留这个……我完全不知道这背后的原理是什么，我其实很好奇……但你需要以某种方式保留一个依赖图（dependency graph），也就是一个人和他所有依赖数据之间的关系图，这样你就能随时准备好处理它。听起来在多台机器之间做到这一点简直难如登天。是的，特别是像外键约束、级联删除，它们有着非常显著的锁（locking）要求：比如在执行删除操作时，确保引用此记录的记录仍然存在，
And so you have to do, you know, you delete that account and then you have to also delete all those other things that are derived from that account. And that's where the cascading metaphor comes from because it cascades into the credit card table and the phone number table and all of that. And so then, you know, to do that quickly, you need to somehow keep this, and I have no idea how this works. I mean, I'm very curious, but you somehow keep a, you know, like a dependency graph, really, of, you know, a person to all of their dependent data so that you have that ready on hand. And that sounds incredibly difficult to do across multiple machines. Yeah, and in particular, like foreign key constraints, cascading deletes have very significant locking requirements as far as like ensuring that, you know, the record that's referencing this still exists
并且同时没有其他东西被创建出来、也可能正在使用这个记录。所以，这确实需要大量的全局协调，以确保外键或级联锁提供的所有要求和约束实际上在整个网络中都得到了维护。因此，在不一定保证这些关系约束的NoSQL世界里，事情就会简单得多。然后你只需在事后简单地处理这些事情：你知道，如果存在一条记录引用了一个已不复存在的记录，好吧，我们要么动态地移除该引用，要么容忍这种情况。所以有很多事情
while we're doing this delete and then nothing else has like come into existence that is also potentially using this. So it does, it simply requires a lot of like kind of global coordination to ensure that all the uh the requirements the constraints that foreign key or cascading locks provide are actually maintained across the network and so you know in the no sql world where you aren't necessarily guaranteeing these types of relational constraints, things get a lot simpler. And then you just simply deal with things, you know, potentially after the fact, where, you know, if there is this record that is referencing a record that no longer exists, well, we either remove that reference on the fly or tolerate that so there's a lot of things that
可以在事后处理，而不是依赖于试图实时维护这种一致性。是的，这说得通。嗯，我的意思是，你触及了一些极其困难的边缘情况。想象一下，你正在删除某个人的账户，然后呢，也许就在他们发出命令后不久，他们去到了另一个标签页，说：“我想删除我的信用卡，只是为了确保它真的被删掉了。”所以现在你会遇到这种情况，你甚至可能会以错误的顺序收到请求——在试图删除信用卡的过程中，又收到了删除信用卡的请求——所以你得到了双重删除（double deletes），或者更糟糕的情况是，如果有人可能在手机上……你知道，某个家庭成员拥有相同的账户，并且他们正在添加一张信用卡，所以你正试图
can be done after the fact rather than relying on trying to maintain uh this consistency in real time yeah that makes sense um yeah i mean i mean you touched on some of the extremely difficult edge cases i mean imagine you're deleting someone's account, but then, you know, maybe they like right after they put the command, they go to another tab and they say, I want to delete my credit card just to make sure it's really gone. And so now you get this, you might get it even in the wrong order where it requests to delete, delete a credit card while you're in the middle of trying to delete the credit card so you get double deletes or you get even worse as if someone maybe on their phone you know a family member has the same account and they're adding a credit card so you're trying
擦除账户，而一张信用卡刚好在中间被添加进去了。有太多可能发生的事情了，而且……如果你有这些外键约束、这些级联删除，就像是你正在设定一个非常、非常硬性的保证。所以如果你甚至连一瞬间的不一致都不允许自己存在，那么你唯一能实现这一点的方法就是按下暂停键。是的，是的，是的，是的，这就回到了那个关于速度的问题，也就是……那些逻辑上不只是一个表的东西，你知道，比如所有那些看起来不只是像Excel电子表格的东西。这算是一种向大家解释SQL与NoSQL的好方法吗？是的。我的意思是，这确实是一个很好的出发点。
to wipe the account and a credit card gets added right in the middle and there's so many things that can happen and um and if you have these these foreign key constraints these cascading deletes like you're putting a very very hard hard guarantee and and so if you're not allowing yourself even for a moment to be inconsistent then the only way you can accomplish that is by hitting the pause button yeah yeah yeah yeah which is getting back to that speed thing is the thing that isn't like a logically a table, you know, like everything that like, wouldn't just look like an Excel spreadsheet. Is that like, what is kind of a good way of explaining SQL versus no SQL to folks out there? Yeah. I mean, I think that is a good starting point. Um, and it is kind of a complicated thing because there's there has been so much wrapped up into like the the notion of
而且这其实是一件挺复杂的事情，因为有太多东西被包裹进了SQL传统数据库的概念里。你知道，我认为这一直是NoSQL背后的主要概念思想，即它是一种文档驱动数据库的概念，
sql traditional databases um you know i think that that has been kind of the primary like conceptual idea behind no sql is that it's a this idea of a document driven database where um yeah the document can be a data structure that has any structure that I want. And I can freely map that to the data structures in my application. And it may look more similar to it. And I don't have to have as much ORM magic that's like doing this translation. But certainly, like, it's also like comparing how things are querying, like NoSQL is obviously a comparison to SQL, which is a query language. And so oftentimes, NoSQL gets wrapped up with, SQL, which is a query language. And so oftentimes NoSQL gets wrapped up with, okay, we're going to have different querying mechanisms for accessing that data.
是的，文档可以是一个具有我想要的任何结构的数据结构。我可以自由地将它映射到我的应用程序中的数据结构。而且它看起来会更相似。我不需要那么多的ORM魔法来做这种转换。但当然，这也是在比较查询方式。例如，NoSQL显然是相对于SQL（一种查询语言）而言的。所以通常情况下，NoSQL会被与SQL纠缠在一起，SQL是一种查询语言。所以通常NoSQL会被与以下概念混在一起：
Maybe it's also wrapped up into the whole relational versus non-relational. And what does that even mean? You know, part of that part of what relational means, at least in the SQL world is like we talked about you do a query on that and there's a known foreign key, you actually have to tell the SQL engine every single time how those, those two tables are supposed to be joined. You have to say, right on this field to this other field. I can't just say, Hey, give me the data that's associated from table two with table one.
好吧，我们将为访问这些数据提供不同的查询机制。也许它还与整个“关系型”对“非关系型”的概念纠缠在一起。这到底意味着什么？你知道，关系型的部分含义，至少在SQL世界里，正如我们所讨论的，你对它进行查询，并且存在一个已知的外键，你实际上必须每一次都告诉SQL引擎，这两个表应该如何连接。你必须说：“将这个字段直接连接到这个其他字段。”我不能只是说：“嘿，给我提供与表一相关联的来自表二的数据。”
It's not part of SQL, right? You have to tell it every time what that relationship is, which is kind of a funny thing. That's such a good point. Such a good point. We've kind of like associated SQL with relational, even though SQL is actually the query language itself, isn't like terribly relational.
这不是SQL的一部分，对吧？你必须每一次都告诉它这种关系是什么，这其实是一件挺搞笑的事情。这真是个极好的观点！太棒的观点了。我们某种程度上把SQL和“关系型”联系在了一起，尽管SQL作为查询语言本身，其实并不是那么“关系型”。
We do all that with ORMs, right? Like ORMs know these relationships. They're the ones that kind of put together these joins. So there's kind of like, just like historically, all of these things that have been associated with traditional databases. And so NoSQL was kind of this effort to like, rethink some of those things, rethink the relational aspect, rethink the querying aspect, rethink the structural aspect, how we store that data. And so it's kind of given us a, you know, a way to re approach that stuff, I think. But it does encompass a lot. And the
我们所有这些操作都是通过ORM完成的，对吧？比如ORM知道这些关系。它们才是把这些连接拼凑在一起的幕后推手。所以，就像历史上所有这些与传统数据库相关联的东西一样，NoSQL可以说是试图重新思考其中某些事情的一种努力：重新思考关系方面，重新思考查询方面，重新思考结构方面，以及我们如何存储这些数据。所以它可以说是给了我们一种重新审视这些东西的方法，我想。但它确实涵盖了非常多的内容。而且现实情况是，
reality is, is that no SQL databases, like, you know, one of the things that I've learned is that you can say that it's not relational, but like, and there's a lot of relational data out there. And even if you aren't doing SQL, and even if you don't have foreign key constraints, I bet your data has some relational properties to it. Yep, yep, yeah, exactly. I mean, you almost always want to reduce on part of the data. So you say something like,
非关系型数据库……你知道，我学到的一点是，你可以说它不是关系型的，但是——有很多关系型数据存在。即使你没有使用SQL，即使你没有外键约束，我敢打赌你的数据也具有某些关系属性。是的，是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，你几乎总是希望对部分数据进行聚合（reduce）。所以你会说类似这样的话：
what is the average or the median number of phone numbers of all the users in my account? You know, is it zero? Is it one? I mean, it of all the users in my account. You know, is it zero? Is it one? I mean, it makes a big difference to my product. And so as soon as you want to start reducing on parts of these objects, then you find yourself like really wishing you had SQL again. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, once you start normalizing more, yeah,
我账户中所有用户的电话号码的平均值或中位数是多少？是零吗？是一根吗？我的意思是，这对我的产品有很大影响。所以一旦你想要开始对这些对象的某些部分进行聚合（reduce），你就会发现自己非常渴望能再次拥有SQL。是的，是的，是的。是的，一旦你开始进行更多的规范化，是的，
it starts becoming more convenient. Yeah, that makes sense. Something you touched on that we should we should explain more detail our orms so yeah i talked about sql alchemy as an example i'm sure there's a ton of other ones but you know um you can write raw sql and you know you or you know really for any database you can write raw queries, and you will get back data. And you can definitely work that way. And there's times where you'll want to do that for certain queries.
它就会开始变得更方便。是的，这说得通。你刚才触及的一个话题，我们应该更详细地解释一下，那就是ORM（对象关系模型）。所以，是的，我以SQLAlchemy为例谈到了这一点，我确信还有一大堆其他的工具，但是，你可以编写原生SQL（raw SQL），你知道，或者你可以为任何数据库编写原生查询，然后你会拿回数据。你完全可以那样工作。有些时候你确实会想要针对某些查询这样做。
There's advantages to that, just like there are advantages to writing some of your code in C, even if most of it is in Python. But by and large, you'll use an ORM for a lot of this work. And the way that works is you can actually have the ORM generate the database. I don't really advocate for that because I feel like you can't change languages then. You're kind of like stuck, right? If your Python ORM generates a database, then you switch to JavaScript and your JavaScript ORM also wants to generate the database. Now what do you do? So either you have to have some leader and everyone else follows or just use something else like Alembic, for example, but it could be anything to generate the database and then SQL alchemy and a lot of these ORMs, they can actually look at the database and, uh, you know, map it in real time to, you know, your, your data types. So just to give a
这样做有它的优势，就像用C语言编写部分代码（即使大部分代码是用Python写的）也有优势一样。但大体上，你会在很多这样的工作中使用ORM。其工作原理是，你实际上可以让ORM来生成数据库。我其实并不主张这样做，因为我觉得那样你就无法更换语言了。你基本上就被“卡住”了，对吧？如果你的Python ORM生成了数据库，然后你切换到了JavaScript，而你的JavaScript ORM也想要生成数据库。那现在你该怎么办？所以要么你得有一个主导者，让其他人跟着它走，要么就使用其他工具（比如Alembic，当然也可以是任何工具）来生成数据库，然后SQLAlchemy和许多这类ORM实际上可以查看数据库，并且……（你知道）实时将其映射到你的数据类型。所以举个
very simple example, um, you know, you might have a class called user. The user has an ID, a first name, a last name, a phone number. These are all just strings in your class. And with some annotations, you can now take that class and turn it into a sort of SQL alchemy, kind of a first class citizen. And so what SQL alchemy will do is look for a table called user. And then if you do something like uh you know give me the user class where the id is three sql alchemy will do sort of the magic to say okay
非常简单的例子，你知道，你可能会有一个名为User的类。User具有id、first name、last name、phone number。这些在你的类中都只是字符串（strings）。通过一些注解（annotations），你现在可以把那个类变成某种SQLAlchemy中的“一等公民”（first-class citizen）。因此，SQLAlchemy要做的事情就是寻找一个名为user的表。然后如果你执行类似……（你知道）“给我查找id为3的User类”，SQLAlchemy就会施展某种魔法来表示：“好的……”
fetch this row from this table turn it into a python class and then give it to the give it to the developer and so it's it generates a lot of really nice uh features for you yeah yep that's exactly right yeah it's really fun i in the beginning i had so much trouble with orms um you know it's one of these things that's not very intuitive especially if you have native nested uh structures um you have to kind of pull those out. But I would encourage your listeners to take the time to learn something like that. Once I learned it, I was much, much more productive. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. And maybe this is a segue into some of the challenges with ORM. Yeah. Yeah. ORMs are great. But one of the challenges that we often face with or Ms is that there's kind of like this, the classic select in plus one problem. And that problem is that oftentimes, you maybe are getting data, and then there's all this related data. And if you do a query, and then start accessing this data, maybe each time you access that data, it has to then do another query to your database, right? This is kind of a common problem is that
从这个表中获取这行数据，把它变成一个 Python 类，然后把它交给开发者，所以它会为你生成很多非常棒的功能，对，是的，完全正确，是的，真的很有趣。我一开始对 ORM 有很多困惑，你知道，这是那种不太直观的东西，特别是如果你有原生的嵌套结构，你必须把它们提取出来。但我鼓励你的听众花时间去学习类似这样的东西。一旦我学会了，我的效率就高得多。对，对，对，对。也许这是一个过渡，引出关于 ORM 的一些挑战。对，对。ORM 很棒。但我们经常面对应对 ORM 的其中一个挑战是，有点像经典的 N+1 查询问题。那个问题是，通常情况下，你可能在获取数据，然后有所有这些相关数据。如果你做一个查询，然后开始访问这些数据，也许每次你访问该数据时，它都必须对你的数据库进行另一次查询，对吧？这是一个很常见的问题，就是
it's actually kind of, it can be challenging to get that initial data with the appropriate SQL query that's going to fetch all the data that you need for your future data when you're accessing the data from the properties, right? And that actually can be, it can be anywhere on the spectrum from like a pretty easy change to how you do the query to like, maybe it's just downright impossible to know ahead of time, based upon how you're going to process this data, what you're going to end up accessing. And this isn't necessarily like a problem, like ORM doesn't cause this problem. It's just kind of making it easier to access the data.
实际上，用适当的 SQL 查询来获取初始数据可能会很有挑战性，这个查询会为你以后访问属性时所需的所有数据进行抓取，对吧？这实际上可能在光谱上的任何地方，从对你如何做查询的一个相当简单的改变，到可能简直不可能提前知道，基于你将如何处理这些数据，你最终会访问什么。这不一定是某种问题，就像 ORM 并没有导致这个问题一样。它只是让访问数据变得更容易了。
And you're still kind of forced to deal with these issues of like what is the appropriate way to query the data so that I'm reducing the amount of back and forth. Yeah, let me see if I... Oh, go ahead. No, go ahead. Oh, I was going to see if I oh go ahead no go ahead oh I was gonna see if I could if I could understand the problem because uh yeah I uh I just want to see if I wrap my head around this so the idea is you know let's say I just want to show someone's first name last name and their phone number but
你仍然不得不处理这些问题，比如什么是查询数据的合适方式，以便我减少来回的次数。是的，让我看看我……哦，你请。不，你请。哦，我本来想看看我……哦，你请，不，你请。哦，我本来想看看我能不能，能不能理解这个问题，因为，是的，我，我只是想看看我能不能弄明白这一点，所以这个想法是，你知道，比方说我只想显示某人的名字、姓氏和他们的电话号码，但是
but the user class has 30 fields in it if I use an an ORM, I'll get all 30 fields and 27 of those are wasted. Is that the problem? Well, that can be one of the problems. But the other problem is, let's say that you're getting this list of users and they each have a relationship with their employer record, right? And so you're doing a join on it. And there's different ways this can work. It can potentially pull in, do that join ahead of time and pull in all that data ahead of time. Or maybe it's not, you just have these IDs that reference the employer table. And then as you iterate through the users, oftentimes ORM will then reactively as you access that employer field, it will then say, oh, I haven't fetched that yet. I will go do a query to fetch that employer record. And so as I go through 30 user records,
但用户类里面有 30 个字段，如果我使用 ORM，我会得到所有 30 个字段，其中 27 个都被浪费了。这就是问题所在吗？嗯，这可能是问题之一。但另一个问题是，假设你正在获取这个用户列表，并且他们每个人与他们的雇主记录都有关系，对吧？所以你正在对其进行连接。这可以通过不同的方式工作。它可能会提前介入，提前进行该连接并提前拉取所有这些数据。或者也许不是，你只有这些引用雇主表的 ID。然后当你遍历用户时，通常 ORM 会在你访问该雇主字段时做出反应，它会说，哦，我还没获取那个。我要去执行一个查询来获取那个雇主记录。因此，当我浏览 30 条用户记录时，
depending upon the way that you initially fetch this data, every time you access that, you are then accessing this related, doing a separate fetch to access this related table. So that's kind of the classic select in plus one problem with ORMs.
根据你最初获取此数据的方式，每当你访问该数据时，你都在访问此相关数据，对相关表进行单独的获取。所以这就是 ORM 经典的 N+1 查询问题。
Oh, now I totally get it. I totally, totally get it. Yeah, that is really painful, right? So if you're writing the SQL yourself, you would know, just join the user table to the employer table and fetch all of it at once. And you just want to query. Exactly. And it's hard for ORMs because you actually kind of have to look into the future a little bit, right? You have to know ahead of time, well, what data is going to be accessed from this, right? So it's challenging. Oh man, that is wild. Yeah, I mean, you know, for an ORM to do this explicitly, you would have to, in my user.get, you'd have to provide a list of all the derived classes that I would want and not want. Right, right, right. Exactly. Yeah. And then this is maybe kind of a segue into thinking about this problem from another approach. And that is kind of going back to the idea of embedded databases. Like, well, what if we made it so that this code that's iterating through these users
哦，现在我完全懂了。我完全、完全懂了。是的，这真的很痛苦，对吧？所以如果你自己写 SQL，你会知道，只需将用户表连接到雇主表并一次性获取所有内容。而你只是想查询。完全正确。这对于 ORM 来说很难，因为你实际上必须稍微展望一下未来，对吧？你必须提前知道，嗯，将从这里访问什么数据，对吧？所以这很有挑战性。天哪，太疯狂了。是的，我的意思是，你知道，对于一个 ORM 要显式地做到这一点，你必须在我的 user.get 中，你必须提供我想要和不想要的所有衍生类的列表。对，对，对。完全正确。是的。然后这也许是一个过渡，开始从另一个方法来思考这个问题。那就是回到嵌入式数据库的想法。比如，好吧，如果我们让这段遍历这些用户的代码
is actually close enough to the database that it can efficiently retrieve these employer records on the fly, right? Like part of the reason why the select in problem is so crippling is because we know that there's a lot of overhead to issuing each query but if the data if this code is executing close enough to the data well the internals of a sql engine is basically doing the same thing like it's i mean there's different approaches to joins but oftentimes when a join is executed it's going through a table getting a foreign key and doing a fetch from another table it's kind of as simple as that you know unless you're doing like hash joins or something like that. But oftentimes, it's relatively straightforward of like
实际上离数据库足够近，以便它可以在运行中高效地检索这些雇主记录，对吧？像 N+1 问题之所以如此致命的部分原因是因为我们知道发出每个查询有很多开销，但如果数据，如果这段代码在离数据足够近的地方执行，嗯，SQL 引擎的内部基本上在做同样的事情，就像是，我的意思是，对于连接有不同的方法，但通常当执行连接时，它会遍历表，获取外键并从另一个表获取数据，事情就是这么简单，除非你做类似哈希连接之类的事情。但通常情况下，它相对直接，就像
just iteratively getting other records. So if that if if data can access that at a relatively similar speed, the way that you know, your internal engine is working, then you're kind of back into the realm of like, the code doesn't need to think ahead. Maybe it's not even again, maybe it's not even possible, maybe as you're iterating through the users, like, maybe there's actually like really complex logic that involves like the permissions of the user, what employer is related to another employer that dictates whether or not that employer record is actually retrieved or not retrieved. Those things may not even be expressible in SQL queries, right? And so this idea of getting code that's working close with the data kind of opens up new opportunities for doing these more complex
迭代地获取其他记录。因此，如果该数据能够以相对相似的速度访问，就像你知道的，你的内部引擎工作的方式一样，那么你就回到了这样的领域：代码不需要提前思考。也许它甚至不是，也许它甚至是不可能的，也许当你遍历用户时，就像，也许实际上有非常复杂的逻辑涉及用户的权限，哪个雇主与另一个雇主相关，这决定了是否实际检索或不检索该雇主记录。这些东西甚至可能无法在 SQL 查询中表达，对吧？因此，让代码与数据紧密合作的想法为动态执行这些更复杂的
levels of data retrieval on the fly, and taking advantage advantage of this low latency access to data. Got it. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, that's a good transition to the last area here, which is the database environment. Just to give an example, I built a kind of like a clone of Google Photos just for my family. So I had a kind of like a clone of Google Photos just for my family. So I had a little Android app and I have a database.
数据检索级别开辟了新的机会，并利用了对数据的这种低延迟访问。明白了。是的，说得通。是的，这是一个很好的过渡，到这里的最后一部分，也就是数据库环境。举个例子，我为我的家人构建了一个类似谷歌相册的克隆版。所以我有一个类似谷歌相册的克隆版，只为我的家人。所以我有一个小型的 Android 应用，我有一个数据库。
I store all the photos on S3, which is this Amazon file system. My database kind of keeps track of the photos. But I ran into this issue where I had a, and I can't remember from using postgres or mysql but i had some sql database but then on my phone i basically needed the database but i can't run mysql on my phone so i ended up running uh this thing called android room which i think is built on sqlite um but that's an example where you know phone, it's just not practical in an Android app or an iPhone app to run MySQL database. And so your environment plays a huge, huge role on what set of databases you're going to be looking at. So if you're on the browser, for example,
我把所有的照片都存在 S3 上，这是亚马逊的文件系统。我的数据库用来跟踪照片。但我遇到了一个问题，我有一个，我不记得是从 postgres 还是 mysql 开始的，但我有一些 SQL 数据库，但在我的手机上，我基本上需要数据库，但我无法在手机上运行 MySQL，所以我最终运行了这个叫做 Android Room 的东西，我想它是构建在 SQLite 上的，但这是一个例子，你知道，手机，在 Android 应用或 iPhone 应用中运行 MySQL 数据库是不切实际的。因此，你的环境在你要寻找的数据库集合中扮演着非常非常大的角色。所以，如果你在浏览器上，例如，
or if you're running on the edge on an edge server, that's going to change the scope and the type of databases you're going to look at. Right. Right, right. For sure. Yeah. Yeah, and fundamentally, as you start
或者如果你在边缘服务器上运行，这将改变你所寻找的数据库的范围和类型。对，对，对。确实。是的。是的，从根本上讲，当你开始
being more concerned about getting access to data quickly, fundamentally, this is a problem of getting data as close to the user as possible. And, you know, I mean, that kind of goes into the subject of like edge based databases where, you know, we're trying to keep data as close to the user as possible. You know, we kind of have a few fundamental constraints here. The speed of light kind of actually dictates like, there are fundamental limits to how quickly you can get data from a very far distance around the world to a user. And the other fundamental constraint is that we know this is one of the most important things to users, right? Like there's been study after study on user interaction where like low latency is absolutely key to a high quality user
更加关注快速获取数据的途径时，从根本上说，这是一个让数据尽可能接近用户的问题。而且，你知道，我的意思是，这有点符合边缘数据库的主题，你知道，我们试图让数据尽可能接近用户。你知道，我们在这里有一些基本的限制。光速实际上决定了：从世界上非常远的距离将数据获取到用户手中，其速度存在根本性的限制。另一个根本性的限制是，我们知道这是对用户最重要的事情之一，对吧？就像对用户交互进行了一项又一项研究一样，低延迟绝对是高质量用户
experience um and so you know i think this is another fundamental uh direction of databases is recognizing that we we do need to get data close to users to if we're going to really try to achieve the optimal experience for users yeah that totally makes sense. I think even in this Android app, you know, it just it just was totally untenable to wait for a database lookup. Like, I just wanted to be able to scroll and see all the photos. And I mean, particularly for this app, because it's meant to look at photos that, you know know your family and your friends who have agreed to share with you have have created but also photos that you had on your own phone and so you kind of feel like why is this taking you know 800 milliseconds to pull up a photo that i took two seconds ago
体验的关键，所以你知道，我认为这是数据库的另一个基本方向，认识到我们需要让数据接近用户，如果我们真的想为用户实现最佳体验的话。是的，这完全说得通。我认为即使在这个 Android 应用中，你知道，等待数据库查找也完全是难以为继的。就像，我只希望能够滚动并查看所有照片。我的意思是，特别是对于这个应用，因为它是为了看照片，你知道，你的家人和同意与你分享的朋友创建的照片，还有你手机上自己的照片，所以你会有种感觉，为什么我两秒钟前拍的一张照片要花，你知道，800 毫秒才能调出来
right and so um yeah and so that uh um you know now also with other you'll see this a lot with even uh games where um there's a lot of transitions you have someone clicks i've been paying attention to a lot of the game design and game art recently that's just the latest kind of kick i'm on when someone clicks new game there's always kind of like a little fade out fade in and i thought about what would this game have been like if they didn't do that and the reality is you know it's hard to tell because they're hiding it with the fade but it probably was going to take let's say at least two three hundred milliseconds to create this game or to get from the new game, the splash screen to whatever's next. And if you don't have a transition,
对吧，所以，是的，所以现在伴随着其他的，你也会在许多游戏中经常看到这一点，那里有很多转换，有人点击——我最近一直在关注很多游戏设计和游戏美术，这只是我最新的爱好。当有人点击新游戏时，总是会有一种小小的淡出淡入，我想过如果这个游戏没有这样做会是什么样？而现实是，你知道，这很难说，因为他们用淡入淡出隐藏了它，但它可能需要，比方说至少两三百毫秒来创建这个游戏，或者从新游戏、闪屏画面转到接下来的任何内容。如果你没有转换，
people can see how long it took to click that button. And that is kind of jarring. I was thinking about when I play really kind of low-budget indie games, that is kind of this thing where you feel like a little bit of a stutter when you click new game and it kind of tells you that this is going to be like not a really professional experience you know yeah um so so it is amazingly like it's a subconscious thing it's one of these things you don't think about until you think about it but but it has an enormous enormous impact latency has an enormous impact on the user
人们可以看到点击该按钮花了多长时间。那是相当刺耳的。我在想当我玩那些真正预算很低的独立游戏时，就会有那种感觉，当你点击新游戏时会感到有点卡顿，它有点在告诉你，这不会是一个非常专业的体验，你知道，是的，所以，所以它出奇地像，这是一个潜意识的事情。这是那种在你想到它之前不会去想的事情，但它有着巨大巨大的影响。延迟对用户体验
experience and it's just a phenomenal degree to which it does it does yeah absolutely yeah i mean even if you like try to use your mouse on a 30 hertz screen it's like just give up yeah and we're talking about you know a, a few milliseconds here, right? Yeah, that's right. Yeah, it's totally wild. It's just something about that synergy of really real time. It is a totally different experience. And you can do things to hide it.
有着巨大的影响，而且它达到的程度是惊人的，是的，绝对是的。我的意思是，即使你试图在 30 赫兹的屏幕上使用鼠标，也是那种想放弃的程度，对吧？我们在这里讨论的是，你知道的，几毫秒，对吧？是的，没错。是的，这完全疯狂。这只是关于真正的实时的那种协同作用。这完全是不同的体验。你可以做一些事情来隐藏它。
But, you know, when you're talking about databases, you could be potentially talking about multiple seconds and you really can't hide that. I mean, you have to get it faster than that. There's no other way. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Yeah, so I know for, you know, for Android, there's room for iOS. Actually, Patrick, do you know what iOS equivalent
但是，你知道，当你谈论数据库时，你可能谈论的是好几秒钟，而你真的无法隐藏这一点。我的意思是，你必须让它比这更快。没有别的办法。是的，绝对的。是的，是的，所以我知道，你知道，对于 Android 来说，有 Room，对于 iOS 来说……实际上，帕特里克，你知道 Android Room 在 iOS 上的等价物是什么吗？
of Android room is like for storing data on phones? No, not short of Googling it. Okay. Chat GPT open. All right. Yeah, ask Chat GPT. But there is something like that for iOS where it's basically a SQLite database, just like Android Room. But I'm sure it has the word framework in it.
比如用于在手机上存储数据？不，除非去 Google 一下。好吧。ChatGPT，打开。好的。是的，问问 ChatGPT。但 iOS 上确实有类似的东西，它基本上是一个 SQLite 数据库，就像 Android Room 一样。但我确信它这个词里有“框架”这个词。
It's like data framework or something. Everything is a framework. But there is something like that on iOS. And so if you're on those platforms, you're almost certainly going to be using one of those. Again, you could load LevelDB, like do some C++ interop type thing on android it's totally possible there's github projects for it but but you know if you're just starting out you know
就像数据框架之类的。一切都是框架。但 iOS 上确实有类似的东西。所以如果你在这些平台上，你几乎肯定会使用其中之一。再说一次，你也可以加载 LevelDB，比如在 Android 上做一些 C++ 互操作类型的的事情，这完全是可能的，GitHub 上有相关的项目，但是，你知道，如果你才刚开始，你知道
use android room i mean it has the vast vast majority of the market share um uh but now you know we so for android and ios kind of a no-brainer. What about for the web? I mean, what are kind of things that people can do in the browser, things that people could do on the edge? What are sort of different options there? Well, in the browser, there's been a few different attempts over the years to provide native functionality. There's Web you know,
使用 Android Room，我的意思是它占据了绝大多数的市场份额。嗯，但是现在，你知道，对于 Android 和 iOS 来说，这是一个不费脑子的选择。那么 Web 呢？我的意思是，人们在浏览器中可以做些什么，人们在边缘可以做些什么？那里有哪些不同的选择？嗯，在浏览器中，这些年来有过几次不同的尝试来提供原生功能。你知道有 Web
web SQL and then the index DB engine. Lately there's been, you know, the efforts to get a SQL light running in a web assembly, which is kind of interesting. Oh, cool. Yeah.
Web SQL，然后是 IndexDB 引擎。最近，你知道，有人努力让 SQLite 在 WebAssembly 中运行，这挺有意思的。哦，酷。是的。
Yeah. So there's been some different, different things in the works for getting data to be, you know, like a database in the browser um you know for most large-scale applications though you typically are dealing more still with like a back-end database and so uh you know edge databases are kind of a big driver for that as far as like there's still a back-end that you're to, but it's as close as possible to the user.
是的。因此，在使数据成为，你知道的，像浏览器中的数据库这样的事情上，有一些不同、不同的开发工作，你知道，然而，对于大多数大规模应用程序，你通常仍然更多地处理类似后端数据库的事情，所以，你知道，边缘数据库是其中的一个巨大驱动力，因为仍然有一个后端供你连接，但它尽可能地接近用户。
Yeah, that makes sense. So, you know, describe for some folks, some folks might have not listened to, we had a whole episode on edge computing. If you haven't heard that one, go back. It's great. But, you know, if you haven't heard it yet, kind of give folks like a little intro to what is what is the edge when people say the edge and what is what is that environment? Sure. I mean, at a basic level, the edge is is about distributing your cloud computing around the world so that there is a server that is close to every person that is accessing your data, your application. That obviously has a huge spectrum of like, how close can you get these edge compute machines to your users? Certainly, if you have more money, you can have 200 server locations around the world,
是的，这说得通。所以，你知道，给一些听众描述一下，可能有些人没听过，我们之前做过一整期关于边缘计算的节目。如果你还没听过那一期，可以回去听听。非常棒。但是，你知道，如果你还没听过，能不能给听众简单介绍一下，当人们说“边缘”时，究竟什么是边缘？那是一个什么样的环境？当然。我的意思是，从基础层面来说，边缘就是将你的云计算分发到世界各地，使得每个访问你的数据、你的应用程序的人附近都有一个服务器。这显然有一个巨大的范围，比如，你能把这些边缘计算机器推到离用户多近的地方？当然，如果你有更多的资金，你可以在全球拥有200个服务器节点，
you're going to be able to get closer than if you have, you know, four locations around the world. But at the fundamental level, you know, you're just simply trying to get your servers as close to your users as possible, and which again, is all about achieving lower latency. Got it. And so when you have a server on the edge, how is that different from, you know, renting an EC2 instance or something and installing Linux on it? What is that environment? Do you get just a whole machine where you can do anything you want or are there restrictions? I mean, there's a spectrum here, just like you'll have with cloud computing as far as whether you you know, whether you can afford like dedicated edge computing or whether, you know, you're utilizing shared, um, shared resources. Um, you know, we do a lot with,
你就能比只有全球四个节点时更接近用户。但从根本上讲，你知道，你只是在努力让你的服务器尽可能靠近你的用户，而这归根结底都是为了实现更低的延迟。明白了。那么，当你在边缘拥有一个服务器时，这与租用一个EC2实例并在上面安装Linux有什么不同？那是一个什么样的环境？你得到的是一个你可以随心所欲的整台机器，还是有一些限制？我的意思是，这里有一个频谱，就像你在云计算中会遇到的一样，关于你是否能负担得起专用的边缘计算，或者你是否在使用共享的、嗯，共享的资源。嗯，我们做了很多关于，
with, um, Akamai and they have a lot of edge capabilities with like edge workers and things like that. Um, but yeah, again, there's a broad spectrum of like what you can what you can afford got it yeah i do know that uh i think amazon relatively recently announced like lambda edge where you can write lambda functions for the edge okay um but i think it's it's only uh it's only node or something or it's only it's some type of j. It's some type of JavaScript run. You couldn't run Python or something, not without converting it first. Right, right. Yeah.
嗯，与Akamai合作，他们有很多边缘功能，比如edge workers之类的内容。嗯，但是，再次强调，对于你能负担得起什么，有一个广泛的频谱。明白了，是的，我确实知道，嗯，我想亚马逊相对最近宣布了类似lambda edge的功能，你可以在边缘编写lambda函数，好吧，嗯，但我想它只是，它只是node或者其他什么，或者它是某种j，它是某种JavaScript运行时。你不能运行Python之类语言，除非先转换它。对，对，是的。
Yeah. So how did that evolve? What's the connection between these edge nodes and JavaScript? And JavaScript. You know, I think the big driver is that JavaScript really has become probably the most advanced primary language for being able to sandbox in an effective way.
是的。那么这是如何演变的呢？这些边缘节点与JavaScript之间有什么联系？以及JavaScript。你知道，我认为主要的推动因素是，JavaScript确实已经成为可能用于以有效方式进行沙盒隔离的最先进的主要语言。
So, you know, being able to take code that a user has provided and execute that on a machine has always been like kind of a challenging task to deal with. Right. Like, is this code going to do something malicious or take too much resources? The thing is, JavaScript has been we have been using web browsers that run. I mean, I've got a dozen tabs open that are all from different sites. This is like the most well-tested, battle-tested system for taking user code and running it on a different machine in an untrusted model where different code can be malicious. It can be doing different things. And so JavaScript has really gone further than any other language in terms of this ability to host code and do so in a safe and secure way and ensure that there's correct limitations on resources. this both with like Lambda, Edge workers and occupied Ed workers, Cloudflare has like very similar capabilities where they're hosting things in JavaScript. And, you know, kind of getting back
所以，你知道，能够获取用户提供的代码并在机器上执行它一直是一项具有挑战性的任务。对吧，比如，这段代码会不会做什么恶意的事情，或者占用太多资源？问题是，JavaScript一直被用于运行网页浏览器。我的意思是，我打开了十几个标签页，它们都来自不同的网站。这是用于获取用户代码并在不信任的模型中将其运行在不同机器上的、经过最充分测试、经历最多实战考验的系统，在这个模型中，不同的代码可能是恶意的，它可能在做不同的事情。因此，在托管代码、以安全可靠的方式进行托管以及确保对资源进行正确限制的能力方面，JavaScript确实比任何其他语言走得更远。无论是通过Lambda、Edge workers还是与Akamai Ed workers类似的Cloudflare，他们都有非常类似的功能，都是在JavaScript中托管内容。而且，你知道，回到
to where I'm working with HarperDB, this is exactly the same model that we're using as well as JavaScript, hosting JavaScript as a mechanism for taking user code and being able to run that across the edge. And JavaScript just works really well because it is, again, so battle-tested for being able to distribute and quickly run in a secure way. Yeah, that makes sense. So let's spend a little bit of time talking about Harper. So where does HarperDB kind of fit here in terms of
我正在合作的HarperDB，这正是我们所使用的相同模型，即JavaScript，将JavaScript托管作为获取用户代码并能够在边缘运行它的机制。JavaScript运行得非常好，因为它再次经过了实战考验，能够以安全的方式进行分发和快速运行。是的，这说得通。那么我们花点时间聊聊Harper。就……而言，HarperDB究竟切入在什么位置？
we talked about just to recap latency consistency scalability um you know language support um relational versus non-relational what is harper db and how does it fit into the picture when should folks use it yeah um i mean it certainly has its roots in terms of storage is like a NoSQL database. It uses document storage mechanisms. Basically, we store the object structures, we actually store in message pack format, because that's a lot more efficient than JSON. But it also is has a lot of hybrid characteristics as well, a SQL query engine and secondary indexing, ACID compliance. And so a lot of those things that really make for robust application development exist built on top of that NoSQL engine capability. Probably one of the maybe distinctive aspects of HarperDB is the fact that it is designed to, again,
我们刚刚讨论了延迟、一致性、可扩展性，嗯，语言支持，关系型与非关系型，什么是HarperDB？它在整个图景中是如何定位的？人们什么时候应该使用它？是的，嗯，我的意思是，它在存储方面的根源肯定是一个NoSQL数据库。它使用文档存储机制。基本上，我们存储对象结构，我们实际上是以MessagePack格式存储的，因为这比JSON高效得多。但它也有很多混合特性，比如SQL查询引擎和二级索引、ACID合规性。因此，许多真正造就强大的应用程序开发的功能都构建在该NoSQL引擎能力之上。HarperDB可能具有的独特之处之一，事实上它是设计用来，再次，
run JavaScript application code and do it basically in process with the database engine. And so to achieve that very, very low latency access between the JavaScript and the database engine. And so to achieve that very, very low latency access between the JavaScript and the database engine. And so when you have fundamentally a user, a client that's requesting data, that can go directly to an edge server. There can be application code that handles that.
运行JavaScript应用程序代码，并且基本上在数据库引擎的进程内完成。从而实现JavaScript与数据库引擎之间非常非常低延迟的访问。从而实现JavaScript与数据库引擎之间非常非常低延迟的访问。因此，当从根本上讲有一个用户、一个客户端在请求数据时，这可以直接去往边缘服务器。可以有处理该请求的应用程序代码。
It can do whatever appropriate queries into the database, fetch data as it needs to, and then respond to the user. And you've had exactly one network hop. And so that's kind of our fundamental goal is this notion that rather than, you know, maybe going around the world to an application server that then makes another hop to a database, then comes back, trying to achieve basically one hop access to data, even through the complexities of application logic, uh, and back to the database. Well, so if you're running on the edge, my guess is it's like, it's a full replication. So each, each node has a full copy of the database. And so so then how do you get around some of those challenges we talked about? Like if if you're ACID compliant and two folks in different parts of the world try to delete the same shopping cart at the node level. And then at the network level, it's eventually consistent. But that actually still means you get all the characteristics of atomic atomic commits, you get
它可以对数据库进行任何适当的查询，按需获取数据，然后响应用户。这样你就只有一个网络跳数。所以这可以说是我们的根本目标，这种理念是：与其绕半个地球去到一个应用服务器，应用服务器再跳到数据库，然后返回，不如试图实现对数据的一单跳访问，即使通过复杂的应用逻辑和返回数据库也是如此。好吧，如果你运行在边缘，我猜它就像是一个完整的复制。所以每个节点都有数据库的完整副本。那么你是如何绕过我们讨论过的一些挑战的呢？比如，如果你符合ACID标准，而世界不同地方的两个人在节点级别尝试删除同一个购物车。然后在网络级别，它最终是一致的。但这实际上仍然意味着你获得了原子提交的所有特征，你获得了
the characteristics of durability, you get the characteristics of isolation, it just means that you basically we aren't employing locking. So I can't lock this this record across the entire database. I can atomically interact with it. But this isn't necessarily a great fit for a financial application where you need to do like a row level lock on a record on an account where, okay, I don't want anyone else changing this while I retrieve this money out of this one account and put it into this other account.
持久性的特征，你获得了隔离的特征，这只是意味着基本上我们没有采用加锁机制。所以我无法跨整个数据库对这条记录加锁。我可以原子性地与它交互。但这不一定是金融应用程序的绝佳选择，因为在金融应用程序中，你需要对账户记录进行行级加锁，即：“当我从这个账户里取钱并存入另一个账户时，我不希望任何人更改它。”
Right. But there's a lot of applications where this idea that, you know, you still have the basic concepts of atomic isolated durable commits. But those can be happening concurrently. We can replicate this data, resolve conflicts based on timestamps as that data comes together. And in doing so, achieve very low latency replication as well as low level uh low latency access to the data well that makes sense yeah um yeah i mean this is uh you know just tying a lot of things together here i remember when world of warcraft i don't know if this is still a still an issue but they had some issue where i guess uh you could be in one part of the world i'm totally gonna get this wrong because i don't know if this is still a still an issue but they had some issue where i guess uh
对吧。但有很多应用程序都具备这种理念，即你仍然拥有原子、隔离、持久提交的基本概念。但这些可以并发发生。随着数据汇聚，我们可以复制这些数据，并根据时间戳解决冲突。通过这样做，实现非常低延迟的复制以及对数据的低延迟访问。好吧，这说得通，是的，嗯，我的意思是，这只是把很多事情结合在一起，我记得当年《魔兽世界》，我不知道这是否仍然是一个问题，但他们有一些问题，我猜，你可能在世界的某个地方——我完全会搞错，因为我不知道这是否仍然是一个问题，但他们有一些问题，我猜，
you could be in one part of the world i'm totally gonna get this wrong because i don't play world of warcraft but you could be in one part of the world and like pass something to somebody who was like right next to you but like in a different part of the world because of the chunking and it would it would duplicate it so it was like you could make a trade and then both you cancel at the same time or something. And just because they were different nodes and they were eventually consistent and their way of reconciling was to just let you both keep the weapon.
你可能在世界的某个地方——我完全会搞错，因为我玩《魔兽世界》，但你可能在世界的某个地方，然后把某样东西传给一个就站在你旁边、却在世界不同地方的人，因为分块的原因，它会复制它，所以这就像你可以进行交易，然后你们俩同时取消或者其他什么。仅仅因为它们是不同的节点，它们是最终一致的，而它们对账的方式就是让你们俩都保留这把武器。
So yeah, Chase Bank is not going to let you go halfway across the world and double withdraw your money. I mean mean that would be nice it'd definitely pay for the plane ticket to singapore or what have you but they're not gonna let that let you get away with that um but for for most situations you know if your shopping cart has the item twice in it because two people in different parts of the globe added the item you know that's just you know that's a glitch that we're just going to have to sort out on the you know like like downstream right in exchange what you get is all of those
所以，是的，大通银行不会让你跑到世界半个地方去双重取款。我的意思是，那倒挺不错，绝对能付去新加坡的机票钱什么的，但他们不会让你蒙混过关的。不过对于大多数情况，你知道，如果你的购物车里有两次相同的商品，因为全球不同地方的两个人添加了该商品，你知道，那只是一个我们不得不在下游解决的小故障，对吧？作为交换，你得到所有这些
things that we talked about that are so important you know that that speed and that latency that definitely you know causes something in your brain to to uh to uh, to be, you know, really, really happy when you're, when you're on a product. Yes, exactly. Yep. We want people to be happy. Very cool. Um, yeah, I have a buddy who's a musician and he says, uh, you know, you, you don't want to play kind of crazy notes. Like you kind of want everybody kind of nodding their head and and you know feeling the rhythm and uh and then he'll save the crazy notes for when he's playing with other guitarists um same kind of thing here you know you want people to feel like they're in this really natural
我们讨论过的重要事情，那样的速度和延迟，绝对会在你的大脑中产生某种反应，当你使用某个产品时，会让你感到非常非常高兴。是的，完全正确。是的。我们希望人们感到高兴。非常酷。嗯，我有一个朋友是个音乐家，他说，你知道，你不会想弹奏那种疯狂的音符。就像你希望每个人都在点头称是，感受节奏，然后他会把疯狂的音符留给和其他吉他手一起演奏的时候。这里也是同样的道理，你知道，你希望人们觉得自己身处一个非常自然的
environment and and latency is is has been proven over and over again to be super critical um for that let's talk about Harper, the company. So we mentioned that you're distributed. Roughly how many people and what's something kind of unique about Harper? It could be your mascot. It could be what you guys do for onsite. What's something that makes Harper stand out from a company perspective. Sure. Yeah. I think we have about 18 people right now and, you know, Harper is named after the CEO's dog. And so it's very much of a cat loving company. Yeah. I actually don't have a
环境中，而且事实一再证明，延迟对于这一点至关重要。让我们来聊聊Harper这家公司。我们提到你们是分布式的。大约有多少人？Harper有什么独特之处？可以是你们的吉祥物。可以是在现场活动中你们做的事情是什么。从公司的角度来看，有什么让Harper脱颖而出？当然。是的。我想我们现在大约有18人，而且，你知道，Harper是以CEO的狗命名的。所以这非常像一家热爱猫的公司。是的，我其实没有
dog myself. I have a cat. I've considered it a small miracle that they hired me despite the fact that i don't have a daughter but i think there's generally been like you know there's been stand-up meetings with chickens on the on the calls and in general it's a very pet friendly uh company so that might be a little bit of a distinctive so oh that is really cool i go to this place called Civil Goat Coffee. And for the longest time, there were goats right there. The goats would come up to you and nudge you and stuff like that. I think they finally got some kind of complaint or something, but they had to put the goats behind a fence. But I was a little bummed. You know, I thought the whole experience was just to watch my kids uh my my uh kids freak out when the goats got close to them that was part of the fun yeah that's awesome yeah yeah well that is really cool well you know you can always go from there to data dog you know it seems to be a recurring theme yeah for sure yeah yeah we've definitely done plenty of data dog yeah that's right very cool um, this is great.
狗。我有一只猫。我认为他们雇用了我，尽管我没有狗，这简直是个小奇迹，但我想总体上来说，你知道，开会有时会有鸡出现在电话里，总体而言，这是一个非常对宠物友好的公司，所以这可能有点与众不同。哦，那真的很酷。我去过一个叫做Civil Goat Coffee的地方。很长一段时间里，那里都有山羊。山羊会走到你身边用头蹭你之类的。我想他们最终接到了一些投诉什么的，所以他们不得不把山羊关在栅栏后面。但我有点沮丧。你知道，我觉得整个体验就是看着我的孩子们——我、我的孩子们在山羊靠近时吓得大惊小怪，那是乐趣的一部分。是的，太棒了。是的，好吧，那真的很酷。你知道，你随时可以从那里去DataDog，这似乎是一个反复出现的主题。是的，肯定的，是的，我们绝对做过很多DataDog。没错，非常酷。嗯，这太棒了。
Anything else that you wanted to kind of get out there? It could be, well, actually, you know, one thing is, you know, if someone's in high school or college, they might be really looking for something that's pretty low barrier of entry. They're not going to want to sign an RFP or anything like that. So for folks who are kind of really just getting started, does Harper have a product for them and how would they get started? Yeah, we have, you can go to studio.harperdb.io and you can sign up for a free instance of the database. And so that's one of the easiest ways to get started. You can also install it from npm so you can do an npm install harper db
还有什么你想聊的吗？可能是，嗯，实际上，你知道，一件事是，如果有人还在上高中或大学，他们可能真的很寻找门槛比较低的东西。他们不会想去签署RFP（需求建议书）之类的东西。所以对于那些刚刚起步的人来说，Harper有适合他们的产品吗？他们应该如何开始？是的，我们有，你可以访问studio.harperdb.io，注册一个免费的数据库实例。所以这是最简单的开始方式之一。你也可以从npm安装它，你可以执行npm install harperdb
and start with a local installation and so yeah those are some great ways to just spin up a harper db instance start creating some tables add some data you can import csv to have some sample data and then you could get started with writing some application code as well, and experience what it's like to have this like fast in process access to data. Very cool. And so just so I'm clear, like, it's meant, you know, it really excels at the edge, but you could run Harper just on your own computer, the server part of it as well. Is that correct? Yes, that is correct. Yep. Yep. And then, you know, in general, like, I think like you've experienced, that's usually like a great way to do development. You know, usually you want to have
并从本地安装开始。所以，是的，这些都是启动HarperDB实例、开始创建一些表、添加一些数据的绝佳方法。你可以导入CSV以获取一些示例数据，然后你也可以开始编写一些应用程序代码，体验一下拥有这种快速的进程内数据访问是什么感觉。非常酷。为了确保我理解正确，它是指，它在边缘表现确实极其出色，但你也可以在自己的电脑上运行Harper，包括它的服务器部分。是这样吗？是的，完全正确。是的。然后，你知道，总的来说，就像你所经历的那样，这通常是进行开发的绝佳方式。通常，如果你要进行任何重要的开发，你会希望有一个
a local instance if you're going to be doing any significant development so that things are fast and direct and you know exactly what's going on and you can look at things in your task manager and stuff like that yeah totally um really cool hey uh chris thank you so much for for coming on the show it's been awesome i really hope we've motivated folks out there to learn about using databases um you know if you have a database class at your university, be great to take it. I know there's a lot of competition. There's a lot of other really exciting classes you might want to take. So if you don't take the database class, definitely take some time to get familiar with databases and a way to store data, retrieve data pretty easily.
本地实例，这样事情就会快速直接，你知道发生了什么，你可以在任务管理器等地方查看。是的，完全如此。非常酷。嘿，克里斯，非常感谢你来到节目中。这太棒了。我真的希望我们能激励大家去学习如何使用数据库。你知道，如果你在大学里有一门数据库课程，去上这门课会很好。我知道有很多竞争。还有很多其他非常令人兴奋的课程你可能想上。所以如果你不上数据库课程，一定要花点时间熟悉数据库以及存储数据、轻松检索数据的方法。
Because it's an incredibly important part of pretty much everything you're going to do in your professional life. And really, just thanks again for coming on the show and helping folks get started with that. Thank you so much for having me. This has been a lot of fun. I really appreciate it. All right, thanks.
因为这是你职业生涯中所做几乎所有事情中极其重要的一部分。真的，再次感谢你来到节目并帮助大家入门。非常感谢邀请我。这非常有趣。我真的很感激。好的，谢谢。
And thanks to everybody out there. We've been going through a bunch of folks' requests for programming languages and topics um we have a um differential equations i think is the next show which will be pretty exciting that's a pretty heavy mathy topic we're going to talk about um we're talking about game engines we have a whole bunch of topics and we really couldn't do it without all of your inspiration, all of your ideas, your emails, and also without all of your practical, uh, support on Patreon. Um, that's really the way that we kind of, uh, keep the show going, get the word out
也谢谢外面的每一个人。我们一直在处理大家对编程语言和主题的各种请求。我们有一个……微分方程，我想这是下一期节目，会非常令人兴奋。这是一个相当硬核的数学主题，我们将讨论它。我们正在讨论游戏引擎。我们有很多主题，如果没有你们所有的灵感、所有的创意、你们的电子邮件，以及如果没有你们在Patreon上的实际支持，我们真的无法做到这一点。嗯，这确实是我们维持节目运转、向大家宣传的方式。
for everyone. And so we really thank everybody for your support on there and we will see you all next show. Thank you. Music by Eric Varndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
所以我们真的感谢大家在那里的支持，我们将在下一期节目中见到大家。谢谢。音乐由Eric Varndollar创作。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，重新混合、改编作品，
but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明署名归帕特里克和我，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。